ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEES ON
THE CENSUS.
WHAT CENSUS DAY APRIL FIRST?
TWENTY TWENTY LESS THAN A YEAR
OUT SO LIKE LEMON MONTHS -- WE
ARE NOW CONVENE OR SENT SECOND
SENSES HEARING OF THE SESSION.
I LIKE TO WORK ON MY COLLEAGUES --
CENTER I'M BIRD MY CO CHAIR IN
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE AND
OTHER BERMAN I UNDERSTAND IS.
OCCUPIED WITH A NOTE TO MAYBE IT
WILL BE ON HIS WAY -- AND AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF SLICK COMMITTEES FOR
BEING HERE AND I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
OUR SELECT COMMITTEES.
IN OUR FIRST HEARING WE PROVIDE
A GENERAL OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLETE COUNT
PROGRAM'S OPERATION PROGRAM
OPERATIONS STRATEGY IN FUNDING
THE DAY WILL THAT TAKE A DEEPER
DIVE INTO ONE OF THE PARTICULAR.
LEE CRUCIAL ASPECTS OF CENSUS
OUTRAGE LANGUAGE ACCESS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT 44% OF
OUR RESIDENTS SPEAK A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT HOME.
AND WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
A READY APPROPRIATE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE FIFTY FOUR
MILLION THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BY THE
GOVERNOR -- WE ARE DEVOTING
IMPRESSED A PRESENT RESOURCES
ENSURING WE GET A COMPLETE COUNT.
HOWEVER BE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE LANGUAGE ACCESS IS
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT --
FOR MANY COMMUNITIES AND
CERTAINLY -- FOR THE MY
COMMUNITY EIGHTY I COMMUNITY TO
BE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
PARTICIPATING.
SO TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL FOCUS
ON HOW RESOURCES ARE BEING
LEVERAGED TO REACH LIMITED OF
ENGLISH PROFICIENT HOUSEHOLDS
AND HOW COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLAN TO DRESS
LANGUAGE ACCESS -- IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO NOW.
BUT MY COACH HERE CENTER OF
BURKE IF YOU WISH TO MAKE SOME
OPENING REMARKS AND THEN THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AS WELL -- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF WE HAVE
ALREADY EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE GET AN
ADEQUATE COUNT FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
UP IN TODAY WE'RE GONNA DRESS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN PARTICULARLY
IN MY DISTRICT BECAUSE OF THE
GREAT DIVERSITY OF LANGUAGE --
BETWEEN THE API COMMUNITY LATINO
COMMUNITY AND MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD IMPLORE THE LEADERS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HERE THE
LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
INTERESTED.
IS IT AS GROUPS COME TO YOU.
AND COME TO US AND HAVE
PROPOSALS TO REACH OUT.
THE THAT WE ENSURE THAT.
WE ADD TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I KNOW THIS
IS BEEN.
EMPHASIZED IN THE PAST.
BUT I I HAVE A CONCERN I HAVE A
CONCERN THAT UNLESS WE UP FRONT
EMPHASIZE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND METRICS. TO
DETERMINE THE EFFICACY OF
WHATEVER WE'RE DOING THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ACHIEVE THE DESIRED
RESULT.
SO I I WOULD JUST WANT TO
UNDERLINE THAT TODAY -- AND THEN
THINK AGAIN -- SENATOR PANTRY
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE YES SUMMER.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE TODAY'S
HEARING THIS IS A TOPIC THAT --
I HAVE RAISED AS A MEMBER OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR FUNDING WITH
REGARDS TO THE CENSUS.
MY APOLOGIES I NEED TO LEAVE IN
A FEW MINUTES OF IT'S OKAY
THEY'RE JUST A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS AT MY HOPE IS.
THIS HEARING WILL HELP SETTLE --
FIRST I KNOW THAT THERE WERE
SOME SURPRISES ABOUT SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE BEING
IMPOSED -- WITH REGARDS TO MONEY
THAT CAME FROM THE R. P. AND I
KNOW SOME QUESTIONS ABOT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND I'M HOPING THAT
IT WILL BE EXPLAINED -- AS WE GO
THROUGH THE HEARING THERE'S ALSO
BEEN SOME INDICATIONS THAT THE
CENSUS OFFICE WILL BE PROVIDING
SOME NEW RESOURCES TO FACILITATE
LANGUAGE ACCESS.
MY HOPE IS THAT -- THAT WILL BE
ELUCIDATED IN TODAY'S HEARING ON
EXACTLY WHAT NEW RESOURCES.
WILL BE PROVIDED BY A GIVEN THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE A
DEVELOPMENT OF A LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN -- WE HAV RECEIVED A LOT
OF CONCERNS FROM THE PUBLIC.
WHO HAVE FELT?
A BIT OUT OF THE LOOP WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT PLANNING AND ARE
HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
WILL BE IN THAT AND MY HOPE IS
WILL HAVE A DISCUSSION ON WHAT
THE INITIAL THINKING AS AS WELL
AS ENSURE THAT A PROCESS WILL.
BE ABLE TO GATHER ADEQUATE
FEEDBACK FROM AROUND THE STATE
ON THIS -- ONE THING I MENTION
OF THE LAST ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON THIS TOPIC WAS
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THERE IS A
REAL MEDIA STRATEGY -- AROUND
COORDINATING LANGUAGE ASSET
ACCESS ISSUES AND I HOPE THAT
THIS HEARING WILL ADDRESS THAT.
I KNOW ALSO THEIR NUMBER OF HARD
COUNT POPULATIONS WITH LOW
LITERACY LEVELS FOR THAT
COMMUNICATE PRIMARILY AND NON
WRITTEN LANGUAGES AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT THE PRESENTATION HOPEFULLY
ADDRESSES THAT -- AND AND YOU
KNOW AT A HIGH LEVEL -- WE
CANNOT HELP BUT WE CAN WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO EXPECT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO WORK WITH
CALIFORNIA ON THIS WE ARE ON OUR
OWN.
AND I HOPE THAT WE WILL PUT IN
WHATEVER RESOURCES WE NEED TO
WHATEVER COORDINATION WE NEED TO
I AND DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY.
UNITY -- REGARDLESS OF LANGUAGE
REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF THESE
COMMUNITIES -- WILL BE ABLE TO
OUT BE OUT REACH TO AND THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO COUNT EVERYONE --
THIS I THINK POSSIBLY COULD BE
THE NUMBER ONE BARRIER TO
ENSURING THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL
TWENTY TWENTY AND I DO HOPE TO
THIS HEARING WILL BE ABLE TO UP
TO WALK TO THESE THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THINK IT'S SIMILAR.
TO OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK.
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS AT THE
GETS HANDS UP AND THEN THAT SOME
EVER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
SOME OF RAMOS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND JUST -- RAISING.
THE AWARENESS OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION I KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LANGUAGE AND
AND ACCESS THIS THERE BUT ALSO --
THE HARD TO COUNT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE INTERESTED TO HEAR HOW
THE OUT REACH INTO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS BEING ALSO
DONE -- WITH THESE BEARS ARE
FRONT OF US.
THE MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU -- I TO WILL HAVE TO
LEAVE A VERY SHORTLY BUT I'M
HOPING THAT IN THIS CONVERSATION.
WE CAN GET A SENSE OF YEAH --
HOW YOU'RE COMMUNICATING WITH
THE VARIOUS COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE I REPRESENT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND OF COURSE IT IS THE
LARGEST ONE IN THE STATE I'M
SURE?
THEY'RE BEING VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
PROACTIVE IN THEIR PLAN BUT IF
YOU CAN SHARE SORT OF OF THE
CONSISTENCY WITH WHICH YOU'RE
COMMUNICATING WITH THE COUNTIES --
ENTER CAM AID.
IN CBO'S AND ALSO SOLICITING
THEIR FEEDBACK AND INTEGRATING
THAT FEEDBACK INTO THE PLAN.
AND THEN ONCE AGAIN RECOGNIZING
THE HARD TO COUNT POPULATIONS --
AND HOPING THAT THERE'S NOT AN
OVER RELIANCE ON WRITTEN
MATERIALS WHEN WE KNOW THAT SOME
COMMUNITIES COMMUNICATE AND
RESPOND -- IN NON WRITTEN WAYS
AND USING NON WRITTEN LANGUAGES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF THE S. CENTER CHANGE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- I'M VERY
VERY A HONOR TO BE ABLE TO JOIN
YOU ON THIS PANEL -- I KNOW
COMING FROM AND I'M SURE YOU'VE
HEARD FROM QUITE A FEW OF US
FROM THE API COMMUNITY BUT ALSO --
FROM THE IMMIGRANT A. B. I.
COMMUNITY WHO DEPEND ON ASIAN OR
ETHNIC MEDIA -- TO TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION -- I THINK THAT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT IS SOMETHING THAT%
WE DO NEED TO LOOK INTO AND
EXPLORE BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL IS
THE STIGMA.
AS TO WHAT THE CENSUS WHAT THE
INFORMATION FROM THE CENSUS IS
GOING TO BE USED.
FOR AND THERE'S A GENERAL FEAR --
AROUND THAT AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO KIND OF WELL A SOME OF
THE CONCERNS BY BEING MORE
PROACTIVE SO I THINK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU SO LET'S SERVE GO
AHEAD IT'S A MOVE ON TO OUR
FIRST THAT WHILE PANEL OR
ACTUALLY FOR SPEAKER.
A PANEL OF ONE SO I WANT TO
WELCOME.
THAT IS SECOND TAG.
WHO'S THE WHO IS DIRECTOR OF
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE WELCOME AND APPRECIATE
YOUR SHARING WITH US SO WHAT THE
PLANS ARE FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS --
FOR A NAY ON HERE YES.
THE GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON DISK TARGET
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLETE COUNTS OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY OFFICE.
YOU CAN SEE FROM MY BIO THIS IS
MY THIRD TIME IN THIS -- SERVING
IN THIS CAPACITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- AND ALSO
SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON RACE AT
THIS THESE AND OTHER POPULATIONS
ARE TO THE US CENSUS BUREAU.
I WILL SAY THIS MAY THIRD AND IT
IS DEFINITELY THE MOST
CHALLENGING SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE BEING INVITED HERE
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE IMPORTANT
ROLE LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAYS AND
REACHING OUR HARDEST ACCOUNT
COMMUNITIES.
JUST TO BE CLEAR THE FEDERAL
OPERATION OF COURSE THE US
CENSUS BUREAU WHICH YOU GUYS
EVER HAND OUT THERE.
ARE THERE ARE KNOWN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE SUPPORT HANDOUTS OR
INCLUDE YOUR PACKAGE IN THE
RESULT FROM YEARS OF RESEARCH
AND DATA ANALYSIS THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED TWELVE LANGUAGES TO
PRIORITIZE -- IN CALIFORNIA WILL
NEED TO EXPAND ON THAT NOTED
THAT THERE TWELVE LANGUAGES ARE
NOT THE HIGHEST A A TOP
TROUBLING WHICH IS HERE IN THE
STATE.
SO THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX TOPIC
AND OUR TEAM IS WORKED HARD OVER
THE LAST THREE MONTHS TO DEVELOP
A REASONED APPROACH WHICH WE
WILL SHARE AND I'LL DO MY BEST
TO EXPLAIN THIS -- THIS TOPIC IN
AND DIG INTO IT SO JUST A QUICK
OVERVIEW I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
COVER HIM FULL TOPICS SO ONE
PROVIDE OVERVIEW AGAIN WHAT THE
CENSUS IS RISK FEDERAL CENSUS
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR WHAT THE CALIFORNIA SENSE OF
ACTIVITIES LOOK LIKE AN OVERVIEW
OF CALIFORNIANS LANGUAGE AS WE
SPEAK WHAT IS LANGUAGE ACCESS
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT A STANDARD
DEFINITION.
HOW WILL PARTNERS BE EXPECTED TO
APPROACH LANGUAGE ACCESS WHAT
ARE THE TIMELINES AND
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH --
ARE IT REVISED PLANNED AND NEXT
STEPS.
SO JUST THE SEPARATION OF ROLES
AGAIN THE RULE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SEPARATE FROM OUR
ROLE THE CENSUS BUREAU IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ENUMERATION
PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES THE
PROGRAMMING OF THE QUESTION HERE
IN LANGUAGE ONLINE AS WELL AS
PRINTING.
THE STATE DOESN'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER THE LANGUAGES THAT THE
QUESTIONERS PRINTED IN OR
PROGRAMMED SO THAT MAKES SENSE
IT'S KIND OF LIKE IN THE SUMMER
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CONTROLLED THE PRINTING.
AND CONTENT OF ALL OR BALLOTS --
SO WE DON'T CONTROL IT LIKELY WE
CONTROL THE BALLOT AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL HERE.
SO THE STATE OFFICE WE ARE TASK
CREATING THE STATE'S LARGEST
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO REACH ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND OF COURSE OF
COURSE GET THEM TO RESPOND.
OF WE ARE SUPPLEMENTING WITH THE
US CENSUS BUREAU IS DOING BUT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO SAID WE
CANNOT DEPEND ON IT WE CANNOT
DEPEND ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT RESOURCES.
TO GET ALL CALIFORNIANS COUNTED.
SO HOW WILL WE REACH HOW
CALIFORNIA REACH THE HEART
ACCOUNT FOR THOSE JUST TUNING IN
REAL QUICK THE MISSION OF THE
COMPLETE COUNT OFFICE ISN'T
INSURER.
ALL CALIFORNIANS GET THEIR FAIR
SHARE FEDERAL RESOURCES AND
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATION TO
ENCOURAGE A FULL COUNT.
LET'S GET ALONG WITH WE REALLY
BOIL THAT DOWN WHAT IS THE ONE
THING.
THAT ALL OF US RELEASE MY TEAM
NEEDS TO DO TO ENSURE SUCCESS.
THAT'S A GOOD EVERY CALIFORNIA'S
FOR THE FOR SIMPLE THEY DON'T
PULL IT OUT.
WE'RE GONNA COULD BE SUCCESSFUL
WE NEED TO FILL IT OUT
ACCURATELY AND COMPLETELY SO WE
MUST WORK TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND
INCREASE ACCESS TO FOLKS CAN
EASILY TELL OF THE FORM.
WE MUST PROVIDE ASSISTANCE AT
THE RIGHT TIME.
IN THE RIGHT PLACE BY THE RIGHT
PEOPLE.
SO BASED ON LESSONS LEARNED AND
BEST PRACTICES WE INTEND TO DO
THIS THROUGH QUESTIONER
ASSISTANCE CENTERS AND KIOSKS SO
I WILL NOTE THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
WHEN WE DID THE OUT REACH
PROGRAM.
THE THE ACTUAL BUDGET LINE ITEM
WAS NOT OUTRAGE IT WAS NONPROFIT
QUESTIONER ASSISTANCE CENTERS
BECAUSE WE KNEW IF WE PLACE
THOSE DOLLARS IN THOSE HARD TO
CONTRACTS.
THEY WOULD HAVE RETURN AND THE
DATA HAS SHOWN THAT THOSE AREAS
WE HAD ACTUAL PHYSICAL BRICKS
AND MORTAR QUESTION ASSISTANCE
CENTERS HAD ALMOST TRIPLE
INCREASE IN RESPONSE RATE FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY SO THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CENTERS AND
KIOSKS IS THAT CENTERS ARE
STAFFED WITH TRUSTED MESSENGERS
WHICH WILL PROVIDE IN LANGUAGE
SERVICES TO ASSIST WITH THE SELF
RESPONSE PROCESS.
KIOSKS ALL SOARING LANGUAGE AND
I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
CONTRACTORS AND COUNTIES HERE
THAT ARE TALK ABOUT THEIR KIOSKS
BUT THEY'RE ON STAFFED.
SO WE WILL ALSO GOING TO
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF MANY
STRATEGIES INCLUDING DATA DRIVEN
TARGET OUT REACHING NO WE HAVE
THIS QUESTION EARLY ON WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN THAT INCLUDES PHONE
BANKING AND CANVASSING BUT THE
REASON WHY IT'S DATA DRIVEN.
IS BECAUSE IF AN ORGANIZATION
DOESN'T LOOK AT THE DATA AND
THEIR FOR CALLING JUST **** SORT
OF COLD CALLING THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE EFFECTIVE IN THIS COULD
BE A WASTE.
AND IF YOU USE DATA GOING OUT
YOU CAN USE DATA COLLECTED IN SO
YOU CAN MEASURE -- TO SERVICE
CENTER -- BERG'S POINTYOU CAN
MEASURE THE RESULTS BY DAILY IN
AND DATA OUT WE ALSO ARE
ENCOURAGING CONDUCTING OF EVENTS
PUBLIC GATHERINGS.
TOWN HALLS AND PROVIDING OF
MATERIALS.
SO WHAT IS LANGUAGE ACCESS
LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS.
IS EQUAL AND MEANINGFUL ACCESS
FOR LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
INDIVIDUALS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
IN THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE AND IN
ACCESSIBLE FORMATS AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HIGHLIGHT OF
THAT IT'S ALSO FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND TODAY WE HAD.
A WEAPON ARE HOPE YOU GUYS TUNED
IN -- WITH THE HELP OF SOME KEY
PARTNERS THAT FOCUSED ON THE
INCLUSION OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES FOR THE SENSES IT
WAS VERY INFORMATIVE.
AND WE HAD OVER TWO HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS SO LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT INDIVIDUALS AND
PEOPLE DISABILITIES ARE
PROTECTED CLASS UNDER FEDERAL
STATE LAW.
AND THE SENATE LANGUAGE ACCESS
SHOULD BE PRACTICAL AND
EFFECTIVE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
RESPONSIBLE STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK
AND IT CAN BE READILY
IMPLEMENTED.
LANGUAGE ACCESS CAN HAVE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS
DEPENDING ON THE INDUSTRY WITH A
RECORD TO HOSPITALS BUT AS OF
TODAY.
THERE IS NO STANDARD DEFINITION
SO I APPRECIATE THIS HEARING TO
HELP US ALLCOME TOGETHER WITH
THE DEFINITION THAT MAKES SENSE
PERCENT THIS OUTRAGE.
SPEAKERS BY THE NUMBERS CENTER
PAT HAD MENTIONED -- HOW MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT OUR PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
REPORTEDLY SO THERE'S TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY LANGUAGES THAT
ARE SPOKEN IN CALIFORNIA?
RECENT ACS STATE INDICATES IT'S
CLOSER TO ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BUT APPROXIMATELY 99% OF
CALIFORNIA SPEAKS THE SET
ROUGHLY THE SAME FIFTY LANGUAGES.
SO HERE ARE OUR CALIFORNIA'S TOP
TWELVE NON ENGLISH LANGUAGES
I'VE DONE THE BIG SIX AND THEN
THE OTHER ARE DOWN BELOW.
THAT'S NINETY THREE POINT 2% OF
ALL INDIVIDUAL ELLIE P. L. IN
THOSE TOP LANGUAGES AND GET
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT -- THE
CENSUS BUREAU THEIR TOP TOLD
LANGUAGES DO NOT MATCH OURS.
SO MOVING FORWARD SO WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS.
IN A WILL BE IN A IN THREE WORDS
WE ALL ARE.
SO I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU HAVE --
REPRESENT HIS REPRESENTATIVES
FROM ALL OF THESE AREAS HERE
TODAY.
SO SINCE WE PUBLISH THE REGIONAL
LANGUAGE AXE LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATION ACCESS STANDARDS
DRAFT IN MID MARCH WE RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT FEEDBACK FROM
PARTNERS EXPERTS.
ARE ADVOCATES AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF AND IN AN EFFORT TO CLOSE
TO PROVIDE CLEAR DIRECTION TO
ALL PARTNERS WE'VE USED THE
VARIOUS THEMES WE HEARD TO
IMPROVE OUR PLAN MOVING FORWARD
HERE'S SOME OF THE THEMES WE
HEARD AND FEEDBACK.
THEY SAID ANY REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE THEY SAID THERE WEREN'T
ANY REQUIREMENTS IN OUR PREVIOUS
DROPPED THEIR STANDARDS THEY
SAID THEY SHOULD BE IN THE FORM
OF AN OPERATIONAL PLAN NOT JUST
STANDARDS. TO ALLOW FOR PARTNERS
TO EFFECTIVELY EXECUTE.
STANDARDS THAT TARGET ONLY THE
TOP SIX LANGUAGES WOULD EXCLUDE
SMALLER LINGUISTIC COMMUNITIES
WHEN WE HEARD THAT LOUD AND
CLEAR.
THE DRAFT DID NOT SPECIFY
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTRACTORS
THAT WOULD RESULT IN GUARANTEED
LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR THE HARDEST
TO KILL POPULATIONS.
WE ALSO HAD REQUESTED JUST
AGGREGATE LARGE LANGER GROUPS IN
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGES WHICH WE
DID NOT GET DOWN TO THE DETAILS
OF THAT.
THERE WAS ALSO CONFUSION AROUND
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTRACTORS
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLANS INCLUDING
COSTS AND COORDINATION OF
EFFORTS ACROSS ALL RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES AND WHAT THE STATE MIGHT
DO TO OFFSET AND LEVERAGE THOSE
COSTS SO THOSE ARE BUT TO THE
THEMES.
SO AS A RESULT OF THAT FEEDBACK%
WE'RE DEVELOPING THE FOLLOWING
WERE USING LANGUAGE MICRO DATA.
UP TO DEVELOP LANGUAGE SUPPORT
TRIGGERS WHICH ALSO SPEAK ABOUT
IN THE NEXT SLIDE WILL RELEASE A
NEW LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATIONS
ACCESS PLAN ON MAY SEVENTEENTH
WHICH WILL ADDRESS THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE HEARD AN OUTLINE
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR CONTRACTORS.
THE REVISED PLAN WILL INCLUDE
HOW THE STATE INTENDS TO SUPPORT
LANGUAGE ACTORS ACTIVITIES WHICH
WILL INCLUDE A DOT ORG WEBSITE
TRANSLATED INTO THE TOP TWELVE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LANGUAGES.
AND TRANSLATED COMMON COLLATERAL
TEMPLATES WHICH WERE WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT ARE THOSE SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TRANSLATE THEM FIFTY
TIMES.
WE'RE GONNA FOCUS ON USING
CONSCIOUS OF CONTRACTORSTRATEGIC PLANS AND OUR REGIONAL
PROGRAM MANAGERS FACILITATING
THE PARTNERS AND OUR UPCOMING
SUMMER IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
WORKSHOPS TO IDENTIFY WHERE
VARIOUS PARTNERS.
ACTIVITIES INTERSECT AND WHERE
THERE MIGHT BE GAPS.
SO THIS NEXT SLIDE I'M GONNA
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE IT'S IT'S THE
MOST COMPLICATED SLIDE I HAVE.
TO EXPLAINS A BEAR WITH ME I'LL
TRY I'LL TRY TO GO I WON'T TALK
IS FASTER THIS.
THE QUESTION IS HOW WILL
CONTRACTORS KNOW WHAT LANGUAGE
TO FOCUS ON SO FIRST OF ALL
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO COVER ENGLISH AND
SPANISH.
SO WE MODELED OUR APPROACH AFTER
EXISTING LAWS WHICH YOU GUYS
HAVE IN YOUR HAND OUTS.
AND SO HERE GOES THE THE REALLY
MORE TECHNICAL STUFF SO USING
LANGUAGE MICRO DATA WE DEVELOPED
LANGUAGE SUPPORT TRIGGERS WHEN I
SING BECAUSE OF THAT MEANS IT'S
AT THE THRESHOLD THAT TRIGGERS
WHERE SUPPORT FOR A LANGUAGE
NEEDS TO BE -- IT NEEDS TO BE
PUT INTO PLACE -- WHICH
INDICATOR CONTRACTORS WHICH
LANGUAGES MUST BE SUPPORTED IN
THEIR GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
WITH THESE LANGUAGE TRIGGERS 93%
OF ALL ELLIE P. INDIVIDUALS IN
THE STATE WILL BE COVERED AND SO
THAT'S KIND OF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THESE THIS WHOLE THING ALL
TOGETHER.
SO WE TOOK LA COUNTY OUT. TO
EXAMINE DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE
THE SKEW ALL THE DATA.
YEAH YEAH WE TOOK HIM OUT WE AND
WE WE WILL EXPLAIN WHAT WE DO
WITH THEM.
BUT WE SAID THE LA COUNTY WOULD
BE REQUIRED LOOK AT THEIR
LANGUAGE TO COVER THE TOP TWELVE
LANGUAGE GROUPS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY FIFTEEN LANGUAGES.
WHICH WILL COVER NINETY FIVE
POINT NINE SIX UP PERCENT OF
THEIR ELLIE P. AND IN SOME OF
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM I
THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THAT -- BUT I WAS
HEARTENED TO HEAR THEY SAID AND
WE WANT TO DO MORE BECAUSE THEY
GET IT THEY GET LIKE A 100% A
100%.
BUT IT JUST COMES DOWN TO
RESOURCES AND IUNDERSTAND THAT
YOU KNOW COME STANDARD HOW MUCH
WILL COUNT COUNT TO GET THAT
LAST. 4%.
SO FOR THE REMAINING GEOGRAPHIC
DATA GROUPS WE SET A THRESHOLD
OF FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT INDIVIDUALS
AND WHAT THAT WAS IS WE TOOK
ORANGE COUNTY AT THE TOP THERE'S
FORTY OF THESE -- DATA AND WE
HAD SIERRA AND ABOUT A COUNTIES
ON THE BOTTOM IN THE MIDDLE WAS
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND BETWEEN.
UP ORANGE COUNTY HAVING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
ELLIE P. AND ABOUT I COUNTY IT'S
YEAR HAVING. NINETEEN HUNDRED
AND SO FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND WAS A
THRESHOLD OF ANY -- GEOGRAPHIC
AREA THAT HAD ABOVE FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND AND THE MEDIAN THERE IS
THE TRIGGER IS 3% OR THREE
THOUSAND SPEAKERS OF THE
LANGUAGE.
LET MAKES SENSE SO OF THEIR
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT.
IF THERE LET'S JUST SAY -- AND
ORANGE COUNTY THEY HAVE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE WHICH
THEY DON'T.
BUT IF IF -- TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
SPOKE AS PARTICULARITY BELOW
THAT THRESHOLD BUT ANY LANGUAGE
THAT WAS ABOVE IT YOU KNOW IT
OUT OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND MAKING
IT SIMPLE THEY WOULD HAVE THAT
TRIGGER.
OF AND FOR LIMITED ENGLISH PER
POPULATION BELOW FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND WHICH IS SOME OF OUR
SMALLER COUNTIES.
THEY HAD COME A SAFE HARBOR OF A
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PERSONS --
TRIGGER THAT MANY DIFFICULT
THINKING ABOUT THIS IS MAKES
SENSE.
GIVE A QUESTION -- DID YOU WANT
ME.
TO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CHINESE
MANDARIN AND CANTONESE.
SO I KNOW THAT.
THE WAY THE CENSUS BUREAU AND
I'M NOT A SPECIFIC EXPERT IN
THIS IS THAT SOME OF THE CALL
SIMPLE I CHINESE ONES WRITTEN
DID ONE ANSWER ONCE SPOKEN OKAY
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible] TO LEARN.
SO ALL RIGHT WELL WELL I GUESS
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE SOME
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ALTHOUGH I'D
LIKE TO THE BROADER QUESTIONS
ARE LATER BUT IS SO.
I MEAN WHEN WE LET'S ENTERTAIN
YOU.
YEAH WHY TO GO DO IT I I I COULD
TRY TO ANSWER YOU CAN TRY TO
ANSWER IT THAT YOU WANTED. TO
ADD LIKE CANTONESE IS A DIALOGUE
YEAH.
THANK GOD.
OF WELL.
WHAT ABOUT THE CANTONESE AND
MANDARIN CANTONESE AND MANDARIN
OF BOTH DIALECTS OF CHINESE
DIRECTLY OTHER DIALECTS BY THE
WAY SO THOSE ARE THE ONLY TWO
THOSE ARE TWO LARGEST DIALECTS?
SO -- SO I'M NOT SURE WHY -- C.
USUALLY C. IS YOU'LL SEE LIKE
EITHER CHINESE PARENTHESES
MANDARIN OR MANDARIN PRINTED THE
CHINESE AND THE JAPANESE I'M NOT
SURE WHY THEY'RE SEPARATED OUT
AS WE HAVE LANGUAGE GROUPS AND
THE LANGUAGES AND IS BASICALLY
HOW THE AMERICAN COMMITTEE
SURVEYS.
DATACOM'S THOUGH RIGHT YEAH SO
IT IS SO THE LISTING I'M NOT
SURE HOW.
CHINESE IS SEPARATE FROM
MANDARIN CANTONESE NOW I'LL TELL
YOU TO OTHER CHINESE DIALECTS SO
THAT THE BUT I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT THE THAT WOULD BE LISTED
SEPARATELY.
AND AND BY THE WAY TO JUST MAKE
EVEN MORE INTERESTING -- THE
CHARACTERS ARE ACTUALLY ALL THE
SAME SO THE WRITTEN PART IS THE
SAME YEAH WELL OKAY WELL THAT WE
WILL GET LIVE I'LL GET INTO THAT.
AT THAT BUT IT BUT THE DIAL
EXORCISTS ARE DIFFERENT LINK WE
OWN TERMS OF SPOKEN AND HEARD
LANGUAGE RIGHT.
YEAH THAT THAT'S EXACTLY WAS AND
SAY BUT I WAS GOING TO ASK ABOUT
I WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO ASK
ABOUT.
A WIDE -- THERE'S ONLY ONLY
GOING TO BE SIMPLIFIED CHINESE
RATHER THAN THE TRADITIONAL
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE WHEN IT'S
TRADITIONAL CHINESE THAT
ENCOMPASSES.
ALL OF THE CHINESE LIKE I CAN BE
TRADITIONAL BUT NOT SIMPLIFIED.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S EVEN
A IN ANSWER TO THAT OR HOW HOW.
I THINK WITH OKAY SO YEAH SO
YEAH SO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
WRITTEN PART SO WE HAVE DIALECTS
BUT THEN WE TALK ABOUT
SIMPLIFIED AND AND I DO WANT TO
GET TOO MUCH INTO THIS.
SO HE CAN CONTINUE PRESENTATION
BUT FOR EXAMPLE.
PEOPLE FROM DEPENDING WHERE
YOU'RE FROM PEOPLE FROM MAINLAND
CHINA HAVE BEEN.
DALY EDUCATE OUT ON SIMPLIFIED
BUT FOR EXAMPLE YOUR FROM TAIWAN
YOU WERE TRAINED AND TRADITIONAL
SO.
WE HAVE SOME WE MAY HAVE SOME
ISSUES THERE WITH THAT SO THAT'S
NOT A DIALECT THING BUT THAT HAS
TO DO WITH THE PEOPLE'S ABILITY
TO READ THE WRITTEN MATERIAL.
RIGHT AND THEN I WOULD YOU HAVE
TO LOOK AT YOUR PRESENTATION
HERE FROM THE CENSUS BUREAU TO
SEE WHICH ONE THERE YEAH.
ONLY SOME OF THEM YEAH AND THAT
WAS THEIR LANGUAGE DATA
CRUNCHING IT.
SO IMPORTANT THE FORMS AN ONLINE
WILL BE ONLY IN THAT.
YES WE DON'T CONTROL THAT BUT WE
CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF OUR
ENGAGEMENT AND OUTREACH.
ARTS ARE NONPROFIT GROUPS WHO
ARE HERE TO TALK ABOUT THAT THEY
CAN COVER ALL THE DIFFERENT
VARIATIONS THAT MAKE SENSE SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING.
THIS MUCH OF I CAN BECAUSE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS VERY LIMITED
YEAH.
AND WE HAVEN'T TURNING IT IS
CONCERNING HAVE TO ALLOW THAT
ACCESS.
THANK YOU TO MOVE ON FROM THE
PUBLIC IS LIGHT.
AT THE CENTER OF BURKE DEAL DID
YOU I'M SORRY QUESTION.
REMOVAL QUESTION IS IT IS WHAT I
JUST HEARD WAS THAT --
TRADITIONAL CHINESE CHARACTERS.
ARE USED BY THOSE WHO ARE.
TAIWANESE IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE.
THE EDUCATED.
ALL NOT ALL.
YEAH BUT PREDOMINATELY.
FROM CHINA AND TAIWAN THEY CAN
READ TRADITIONAL.
THAT'S THAT'S MY TAKE A GUESS IN
TALKING TO A LOT IS JUST TO PUT
A PIN IN THIS SEEMS LIKE A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA.
EN I I'D HEARD WHAT YOU SAID
THAT THAT'S BEYOND OUR CAN HERE --
BUT HOW DO WE INFLUENCE AT THAT.
SO WHAT IS IT IS WITH WITH THE
ACTUAL FORM LIKE WE CAN'T CUT IT
IT'S ONLY AND ACCORDING TO US
CENSUS BUREAU IT'S GOING TO BE.
IN SIMPLIFIED CHINESE YEAH
THAT'S ALL.
AROUND ME [inaudible]
THE PHARMACY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
US CENSUS IS DOING [inaudible]
QUESTION [inaudible]
LATER.
AND THEN PART [inaudible]
WE CAN [inaudible]
STATE AGENCY YOU TALK ABOUT
WATER EVEN IN THE VERY VERY
GRASS THAT ARE -- THAT IS YEAH
YEAH YEAH.
REGARDING WHAT THE US CENSUS HAS
DECIDED THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO YOU GUYS UNDERSTAND THE
TRIGGERS OF OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA
RIVER -- REQUIRE OUR CONTRACTORS --
AND SO WE JUST GET THROUGH IS
RECORDED WITH THE QUESTIONS SO
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE
GOT FEEDBACK WHICH WAS ARE YOU
GOING TO HAVE A REQUIREMENT
WHERE DOES THAT FIT IN.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S A MEMBER TO HAD SAID
WHAT ARE THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY NEW
REQUIREMENTS SINCE NOVEMBER
SINCE RE RELEASED.
THE STRATEGIC PLAN REQUIREMENT
SECTION ONE POINT FOUR AND
SECTION ONE ONE ONE POINT SIX
SIX ONE POINT FOUR WAS A
QUESTION ASSISTANCE CENTERS
WHICH AGAIN IS A CENTERING PIECE
YOU GOT TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE.
AND YOU GOT TO HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK THE RIGHT
LANGUAGES WHETHER BE SIMPLIFIED
OR WHAT HAVE YOU AT THE RIGHT
TIME TO GET THESE PEOPLE BECAUSE
WERE SO LIMITED WITH WHAT THE
CENSUS BUREAU IS OFFERING US.
IN ORDER TO ANSWER -- SO WE
REQUIRE WE'RE REQUIRING ALL OF
OUR CONTRACTORS TO IDENTIFY
THEIR QUESTIONS SYSTEM CENTERS
AND THEY CAN DO THAT FROM THE
HARD TO COME OUT.
LIKE OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT GONNA
PUT A QUESTION IS IS THAT ARE IN
THE SACK WHERE I LIVE THE SART
ACCOUNT.
SO THEY HAVE THOSE MAPS AND SO
WE'RE WE ARE REGIONAL COMMANDERS
ARE WORKING WITH THEM.
THAT SECTION ONE POINT FOR THE
SECTION ONE POINT SIX WAS IS
LANGUAGE ACCESS WHEN THE LAVA
COUNTRIES LIKE I'M NOT SURE IT
IS TO DO WE'RE COMING OUT WITH
ADDITIONAL.
GUIDANCE WHICH IS TELL US WHAT
LANGUAGES YOU'RE GONNA PUT THOSE
QUESTIONNAIRES ISN'T CENTERS AND
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
WE GOT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS IN THE LANGUAGE AT THE
RIGHT TIME IN THE RIGHT PLACE
STEP BY THE RIGHT EOPLE.
AND THAT'S WHERE OUR COMMITTEE
BASED GROUPS THAT YOU'RE GONNA
BE HEARING FROM COME FORTH TO BE
ABLE TO SAY I KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
COMMUNITY AND THAT COMMUNITY AND
I AM GOING TO BE ABLE MISSING
I'M A PREVIOUS GROUP IS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
THAT OUR REAH THAT'S WHY THE
MORE JORDY OF OUR DOLLARS ARE
GOING OUT TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
GROUPS SO THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO FOR THE STRATEGIC
PLAN ELEMENTS OF REQUIREMENT
THAT'S COMING UP TO DO.
MAY JUNE -- THE NEXT STEPS WE
HAVE OR LANGUAGE DATA WHICH WE
CONTROL THESE -- INTO INTO A
SPREAD SHEETS WERE TO PUBLISH
THAT ON OUR WEBSITE I HAVE SOME
OF IT THEY'RE PRETTY LONG
SPREADSHEETS BY COUNTY.
ARE A MYSTERY CBO'S AND COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO IDENTIFY THOSE QVC
LOCATIONS WITH THE LANGUAGE
SUPPORT CAPACITY TO INCLUDE IN
THEIR STRATEGIC PLANS THAT WE
GET THAT SOME REALLY BE LIKE.
I KNOW I NEED SOMETHING HERE BUT
I CAN'T STOP IT.
AND SO THAT'S ABOUT HOW WE
COORDINATOR I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
A RESOURCE RIGHT HERE RIGHT NOW
IN JUNE BUT THAT'S WHAT JUNE
JULY AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER ABOUT.
IS MAKING SURE IN DURING OUR
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WORKSHOPS
THEY WERE BRINGING THE RIGHT
FOLKS TO TO FILL THOSE SPOTS TO
PROVIDE THAT ACCESS.
SO RPM'S AND CONTRACTORS ARE
GOING TO IDENTIFY THOSE GAPS
AGAIN DO WE HAVE GAPS -- AND
THEN OR LANGUAGE EDUCATION
ACCESS PLAN THE WRITTEN ONE WILL
BE OUT ON THE SEVENTEENTH BUT WE
DON'T THINK PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
TO WAIT BECAUSE THE DATA IS OUT
THERE.
AND WITH THE MAPS ARE OUT THERE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR SHE
PLANTS.
SO WITH THAT I KNOW THERE'S
PROBABLY SOME QUESTIONS PROBABLY
SOME TECHNICAL ONES THAT I'M NOT
ABLE TO ANSWER BUT HOW TO
MOTIVATE US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SEMI
BERMAN I KNOW YOU HAD CAME AND
THEY DID YOU WANT TO MAKE SOME.
INITIAL REMARKS FIRST BEFORE YOU
LAUNCH INTO THE QUESTIONS I I
DON'T THINK SO I THINK IT'S A
NUMBER -- TWO KINDA YEAH GRAB MY
REMARKS AND ENDING CORPORATE OF
THOSE AND HIS -- JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YEAH -- ABILITY
TOHAVE A DEEP DIVE ON IT WHAT'S
WHAT'S A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
CONCERNS AND FEEDBACK FROM FROM
OUR COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT.
AND ALL SAVE OTHER QUESTIONS.
FOR THE PROCESS OKAY SO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY ROOM THIS SUMMER
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THE GIANTS FOR OPENING UP THE
HORNET'S NEST EARLIER.
BUT I THINK IT BEGS THE QUESTION
TRULY ABOUT LANGUAGE ACCESS
ESPECIALLY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
I MEAN THERE ARE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX LANGUAGES AND
DIALECTS ARE SPOKEN IN LA
UNIFIED.
AND THAT SHOULD BE AN INDICATION --
YOU KNOW ON ITS OWN THAT HOW WE
TACKLE THIS ISSUE -- NEEDS TO BE
REALLY THOUGHTFUL AND EXPANSIVE
BECAUSE MANY OF THOSE STUDENTS
AND FACT ARE COMING OR COMING
FROM OUR LIVING IN HARD TO COUNT.
COMMUNITIES -- AND SO MEETING
THEM WHERE THEY ARE EITHER
THROUGH THE WORK WITH THE COUNTY
OR DO THE WORK WITH THE A. CBO'S
WILL BE CRITICAL -- AND
RECOGNIZING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN NON WRITTEN LANGUAGES
THAT ARE USED IN WRITTEN
LANGUAGES.
AND WHERE THAT MEDIUM IS SO
CONTINUED KIND OF THOUGHT ON
THAT IS -- WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
ME AND LA COUNTY IS GONNA BE
PRESENTING AT THE EXPENSE OF
OKAY.
SO ACTUALLY -- I HAD SOME
QUESTIONS WHY CLEAR FACTS A IN
TERMS OF YOUR TESTIMONY THE
FIRST OF ALL AND I KNOW THAT.
SIMILAR TO RAN THROUGH A WHOLE
BUNCH OF QUESTIONS I WANNA LOOP
BACK AROUND TO CLARIFY -- SO
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM SOME
COUNTIES IN A CBO'S THAT THEY
DID THAT THEY FELT.
WELL THEY THEY EXPRESS THAT THEY
ARE THAT THEY DID NOT KNOW
THERE'D BE ADDITIONAL.
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON THEM.
RELATED WHEN THEY WERE OFFERED
THE FUNDS ARE DISPLAYED FOR THE
R. F. P..
SO -- REGARDING THE ON THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PIECE CAN CAN
YOU [inaudible]
SO IS.
SO IS SO BASICALLY.
I'M HEARING A BIT OF AN
EXPECTATION OF OKAY WE WAITING
FOR THE LANGUAGE PLAN WHICH DOES
COME OUT IN MAY.
YOU MENTIONED THERE IS DATA OUT
THERE SO IN TERMS OF WHAT WAS IN
THE R. F. P. ITSELF AN
EXPECTATION FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
SIGNED UP AND NOW YOU'VE
SELECTED.
OUR DAY SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
LANGUAGE ACCESS WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT YEAR -- THAT THEY
APPLIED FOR OUR DAY GOING TO GET
ANY ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
ARE WAS THE EXPECTATIONS LOOK
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE FEW WAS
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT YOU HAD TO
DO FOR THE MONEY YOU GOT AND YOU
PRIDE IN READ WELL ENOUGH SO ARE
I DON'T KNOW.
IN ONE POINT FOUR INSTEAD OKAY
ONE POINT SIX SIX ONE POINT FOUR
IS ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RESOURCES AND IT CLEARLY SAYS
LAY OUT YOUR QUESTIONNAIRE
ASSISTANCE CENTERS NOW IF THEY
DECIDED THEY WERE GONNA ONLY DO
IN ENGLISH.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A PROBLEM
BECAUSE SECTION ONE POINT ONE IS
WHO ARE YOUR HARD TO COUNT AND
HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY'RE HARD TO
COUNT.
RIGHT YOU GOT IT THAT WAS THE
VERY FIRST THING IF YOU'RE GONNA
APPLY FOR THESE DOLLARS YOU
BETTER KNOW WHERE YOUR HEART
ACCOUNT IS HERE OUR MAPS.
SECTION ONE POINT SIX WAS
CLEARLY LANGUAGE -- AND CAN A
LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS PLAN AND IT LAID OUT TELL
US WHAT STRATEGIES ARE GOING TO
USE TO MEET THOSE FOLKS WHO.
ARE NOT NOT ARE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT SO IT'S BEEN IN THERE
SINCE NOVEMBER.
LET ME JUST CLARIFY THIS THAT
AND SO WHAT I HEAR YOU SAYING IS
THAT YOU ASK THE APPLICANT'S
QUESTIONS AND ASSUME THEY
PROVIDED ANSWERS UNDER
APPLICATION.
THAT YOU COULD REFER.
TO DATE BUT AND ALSO THE A CB ES
YEAH AND THE C. B..
OKAY IN CVS.
WHAT I'M NOT CLEAR ON IS THE DO
YOU SAY EXPLICITLY IN ORDER THAT
YOU WILL SO YOU SAID WELL WHAT'S%
YOUR PLAN AND I DON'T?
KNOW I EIGHT SECTION TODAY YEAH
AND AND SO.
THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY SAY THEY
WERE GOING TO DO THIS WITH
EXISTING MONEY AND THEIR
RESPONSES OR DID YOU ARE AT SOME
PLACE AND THE OUR FEE IT SAYS
THE EXPECTATION IS IS THAT.
IN YOUR PLAN THAT YOU PROPOSE
YOU WILL COVER ALL OF THE
LANGUAGES THE YOU KNOW AS YOU
DESCRIBED HERE THAT MEET THOSE
TRIGGER POINTS OR WHATEVER
RIGHTS I JUST WANT TO GET
CLARIFICATION ABOUT THAT DIDN'T
PROVIDE TRIGGER POINTS BUT WE
DIDN'T GO IT WE DIDN'T EXPECT WE
DIDN'T GET.
ANY PLANS AT SAID WE'RE ONLY
GOING TO DO ENGLISH BECAUSE
RIGHT BUT THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WE'RE ONLY
GOING TO DO ENGLISH AND DO YOU
GOT TO COVER HOWEVER X. NUMBER
OF LANGUAGES THAT MEET.
THOSE STANDARDS AND YOU CAN HAVE
A LOT THERE'S A LOT SPACE
BETWEEN THAT POINT AND THAT
POINT.
AND AGAIN I'M NOT THE ONE WHO
REVIEWED ALL THE APPLICATIONS
BUT WHAT I HEARD YOU JUST SAY IS
YOU POSE PEOPLE'S QUESTIONS THAT
THEY NEED TO ANSWER IN YOUR
APPLICATIONS IS THAT WHAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WROTE AND APPLICATIONS
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE ABLE --
TO THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
BASICALLY COVER ALL THE
LANGUAGES THAT.
I KNOW YOU DIDN'T EXPLICITLY
EXPRESSED TO TRIGGER POINTS I
AND I'M JUST WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A CLEAR EXPECTATION
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT IN THE END.
RIGHT THOSE WERE TRYING TO BUILD
THIS AIRPLANE IS KIND OF FLIGHT
ELEVEN MONTHS.
IS THAT.
YEAH WILLIAM ONE SHOT AT THIS
AND SO -- IT FOR EVERY TEN YEARS
AND SO.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE A SITUATION LIKE
THAT MORE JUST ENGLISH BUT WHAT
HAPPENS IF THEY ONLY HAVE. SIX
LANGUAGES IN YOUR TRIGGER POINTS
ARE FOR YOU KNOW TWENTY RIGHT.
WHAT'S THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
WHAT HAPPENS.
SO WITH OTHERS YOU HAVE TO
SEPARATE THERE'S COUNTIES WHO
RAN THERE'S COUNTIES THEY
APPLIED IF THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
OFTEN THEY DON'T OFTEN.
CLEARLY IN THE PLANET SAID TELL
US WHAT YOUR LANGUAGE ACCESS
CAPABILITIES ARE FOR THE BASED
ON WHO YOU'RE HARD TO COUNT OUR
SO IF.
I AND AGAIN THEY LAID THOSE OUT
WE CAN SHOW YOU THOSE BUT THEIR
STRATEGIC PLANS ARE DUE TILL MAY
THIRTIETH AND SO THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR US TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL -- ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE ABOUT WHAT WE WANT THEM
TO DO AND WHAT TRIGGERS THAT WAS
SO SO BASICALLY.
THEIR STRATEGIC PLANS DO AND MAY
THIRTIETH BUT YOU'RE NOT COMING
OUT WITH YOUR PLAN UNTIL MAY
SEVENTEENTH WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM OKAY IDENTIFY THOSE IN
GETTING THEIR INPUT WE MET WITH
OVER THIRTY ONE DIFFERENT
ADVOCATES.
AND COUNTIES IN PUBLIC IN TERMS
OF GETTING THE FEEDBACK WE PUT
OUT STANDARDS AND SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT CAME BACK FROM
ADVOCATES WAS WE WANT
REQUIREMENTS.
YOU NEED TO REQUIRE SO WE SAID
OKAY WILL WE GOT A REQUIRE THESE
AGAIN THIS IS TWO YEAR WE DO
STANDARDS WHICH IS KIND OF DOWN
HERE OR DO WE REQUIRE DO
REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS MUCH MORE
CLOSER TO A MANDATE.
SO THAT'S THE COUNTIES ON THE A
CBO'S THEY DID APPLYING AND
THERE WERE A NUMBER DIFFERENT
CBO'S AND THEY SHOWED THEIR
LANGUAGE SKILLS BASED AND THEIR
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZING SKILLS.
AND COVERAGE OF IT AGAIN THEIR
STRATEGIC PLANS BECAUSE WE CHOSE
THEM BECAUSE THEY SHOW THAT THEY
HAD PROMISE.
OR DO A LATER IN JULY JUNE JULY.
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH THEMTO
IDENTIFY BECAUSE WE GOTTA MASH
THE COUNTIES -- AND THE A. CBO'S
TO GET THAT COVERAGE IDENTIFY
GAPS ARE NOT GOING TO BE DONE IN
A VACUUM OR SUB OKAY SO I
APPRECIATE YOU ASK THEM ABOUT
THEIR CAPACITIES.
I THINK PERHAPS PART OF THE
REASON YOU'RE HEARING A LITTLE
BIT AND AGAIN I'M NOTYELLED
FROM PEOPLE ABOUT REQUIREMENTS
IS IS THAT.
SO PEOPLE MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES.
DO THEY ALL ADD UP.
SUFFICIENTLY TO ACHIEVE.
THE STANDARD THAT YOU'VE PUT OUT
HERE I MEAN BECAUSE AND IN THE
END -- YEAH PEOPLE MAY HAVE
VARYING CAPACITIES AND I SURE
YOU PICK PEOPLE WHO HAVE GREATER
CAPACITIES BUT EVEN THAT AND
THAT'S ALSO THE TEN OUR
RESOURCES.
SO THE QUESTION IS IS THAT.
IN IN THE END ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE WHO CAN ACTION TO
THOSE WHO HAVE THE LANGUAGE
CAPACITY TO MEET THE VERY.
DIVERSE NEEDS OF I CALIFORNIA
RANGING FROM LOS ANGELES WITH
ALL THE LANGUAGE HAS THAT YOU
HEARD.
SACRAMENTO I'M HEARING FROM
PEOPLE THEY'RE VERY WORRIED THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR DAY WON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES -- AND YOU
KNOW IT'S GREAT YOU HAVE ENGLISH
AND SPANISH AND THOSE ARE VERY
TWO VERY IMPORTANT LANGUAGES --
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES OUT THERE -- FOR
VARIETY DIFFERENT GROUPS AND
I'LL TELL YOU THE API COMMUNITY
I'M HEARING A LOT OF CONCERN
THAT.
NAME THEIR LANGUAGES WILL BE
YOURSELF THAT SOMEONE'S NOT
THERE.
WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM.
SO WE CAN YOU GUARANTEE ME TOO
ME THAT SOMEBODY WILL BE THERE --
TO TO TO HELP THEM OUT SO THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE LET TO
NEARBY TO ME BECAUSE WE DID A
AMENDMENT TO THE RP FOR THEY
CBO'S WE REQUIRE THE TOP SIX
LANGUAGES.
AND THE FEEDBACK WE GOT WAS THE
TOP SIX LANGUAGES WOULDN'T.
INCLUDE THE SMALLER LINGUISTIC
COMMUNITIES -- BUT IT DID COVER
IN SMALLER COUNTIES IT MADE THEM.
THE COULD BARELY GET TO THE TOP
SIX BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE.
A TOP SIX LANGUAGE SO NEVADA
COUNTY AND SIERRA -- THEY DO
SPANISH BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT
THEIR BREAKDOWN OF LANGUAGES IT
GOES DOWN.
TO YOU KNOW [inaudible]
THE PHARMACY.
GOES DOWN. TO ELEVEN PEOPLE
SPEAKING GERMAN.
OKAY THOUGHT WHAT WITH THE OKAY
ALL RIGHT BUT BUT LET'S THE BUT
WE HAVE LARGER COUNTIES YEAH.
RIGHT AND SO THE PROBLEM IS
YOU'RE TELLING ME ABOUT THE
SMALL AREA AS WAS SMALLER COUNTY
OBVIOUSLY THE PEOPLE THERE ARE
VERY IMPORTANT AND THEY REALIZE
THAT PERHAPS YOU KNOW.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE COVERS
MANY LANGUAGES.
BUT YOU CAN'T SAY WELL BECAUSE
WHICH COUNTY WHICH COUNTY YOU
TALK TO VETERANS YES YOU DID
BECAUSE SUTTER BASICALLY IF YOU
GO DOWN THE SIX AND ELEVEN
PEOPLE THAT YOU APPLY THE SAME
STANDARD TO SACRAMENTO OR
CERTAINLY TO LA.
RIGHT THAT'S WHY WE DID THESE
NEW TERMS BECAUSE ORIGINALLY THE
TOP SIX WOULDN'T AND IT WAS
ACTION THAT WAS LOW IT'S WHEN
THEY'RE THE TOP SIX WASN'T
EQUITABLE SO WE WENT BACK AND
DID OUR RESEARCH.
AND THAT'S WHY WE TOOK LA OUT OF
THE MIX BECAUSE IT SKEWS IT AND
WE TOOK THE MEDIAN OF THOSE
FORTY GEOGRAPHIC WERE RE DUG
DEEPER WITH THE MICRA DATA FROM.
HOMES AND WE LOOKED AT IT AND WE
SAID FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND IS THE
MEDIAN AND EVERYBODY.
THIS IS OF THAT -- SO WHAT I'M
SAYING IS IS THAT THAT'S WHY I
THINK PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
WATER REQUIREMENTS RIGHT I MEAN
SO I HEAR IS THAT YOU ASK PEOPLE
TO DESCRIBE THE CAPACITY.
AND THAT'S GREAT.
AND I UNDER THAT RIGHT BUT IN
THE END [inaudible]
WHEN CENSUS?
DAY COMES OUR SENSES MONTH APRIL.
TWENTY TWENTY WE NEED TO BE SURE
THE PEOPLE ARE PLACED AT LEAST
MEET THE STANDARDS THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED HERE TODAY AND CAN YOU
GUARANTEE THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
AND IF THE IF IT TURNS OUT THE
TOWNIES AND THE AC VEAS AND I
REALIZE THERE'S A BIT OF
INTERWEAVING.
ARE NOT ABLE TO MEET THAT
STANDARD AND WE KNOW THIS IS
THIS WE'RE HEADING INTO IT WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO DO TO FILL IN
THAT GAP BEFORE CENSUS DAY
HAPPENS.
SO WE ARE YOU KNOW LESS THAN A
YEAR OUT.
OF OUR IMPLEMENTATION PLANS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
HOUSE THE COUNTIES AND THE CBO
IS DO YOU HAVE THAT CAPACITY I
CAN'T.
LOOK AT MY COST BY HAVE TO ASK
THEM DO YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY IN
YOUR PLANNING THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO DO OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS.
DO YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE THAT
CAPACITY BUT THEY HAVE TO START
WITH WHERE THE MAP IS AND WHERE
THE PEOPLE ARE.
AND AS WE IDENTIFY THOSE THEN
WE'LL HAVE TO LOOK INTO OTHER
PRIVATE FUNDING IS THE
GOVERNOR'S CHIEF OF STAFF SAID
WE EXPECT PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS TO
PUT DOLLARS UP FRONT. TO FOR
SOME OF THOSE MAJOR SMALLER
LANGUAGES THAT ARE COVERED OKAY
SO I A SCIENCE SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY WHAT I'M HEARING NOW IS
THAT BECAUSE THE OTHER PART
THAT'S GOING ON HERE THAT I
THINK.
MOST OF THE MEMBERS THE COMMUTER
WHERE'S WE'RE GOING TO OUR
BUDGET PROCESS RATES MAY WILL
HAVE MAY REVISE AND PROBABLY
COUPLE WEKS.
AND THEN WILL PROVE A BUDGETS --
HOPEFULLY SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
BEFORE THE END OF JUNE -- SO BUT
WHAT YOU JUST WHAT YOU JUST SAID
IN MY CLEAR FIVE BE SURE THAT I
HEARD IT CORRECTLY.
THAT THE EXPECTATION IS IS THAT
IF THAT WHILE YOU'RE DOING THIS
PLANNING IF THERE IS A GAP.
THAT YOU'RE EXPECTING PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS THE FIND THE
RESOURCES TO COVER THAT GAP.
I'M GAS BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
COUNTY TO COUNTY YOU'LL NOTICE
THAT A TOP LANGUAGE THAT'S OVER
3% TRIGGER IN FRESNO.
IT IN THEIR TOP ONE AND IT MAY
NOT BE HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
I MEAN MAYBE AMONG IS ON THEIR
TOP. 3% AND ABOVE BUT IS IT'S
BELOW IN TERMS OF SACRAMENTO
THEY HAVE THAT COVERAGE WE WANT
TO MARRY THEM UP TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF THEIR
DOING THAT CAN PROVIDE THE
TRANSLATED MATERIALS AND SHARE
THOSE.
WILL BE SHARING ACROSS COUNTIES
OKAY APPRECIATE SHARING.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO BE SURE WE PROVIDE THAT
LANGUAGE ACCESS I THINK THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN THE INTENTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND I AND MY COLLEAGUES TO SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES RIGHT NOW I'M NOT
FEELING PARTICULARLY CONFIDENT
FOR SOME REASON.
I WANT TO AND HAVE THE REASSURED
THAT WE WILL CLOSE THAT GAP BY
APRIL.
TWENTY TWENTY AND I DON'T DECIDE
REALIZE THAT YOU SO I MEAN IT'S
GREAT YOU'RE ASKING PEOPLE OUT-CAPACITY.
BUT THERE ALSO NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I WANNA BE SURE AM OF
PUTTING A LOT OF RESOURCES INTO
THIS.
AND OTHER HEARING BACK FROM
PEOPLE THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
CLARITY AND ALSO THAT THERE MAY
BE INSUFFICIENT RESOURCES.
RIGHT OR THERE COULD BE ENOUGH
RESOURCES THE FACT OF THE MATTER
TO STAR JUSTIN HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY SO
WE HAVE AN AND I'M PRESIDENT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES ALREADY
DEDICATED TO THIS EFFORT.
AND AS WE GO THROUGH THE
PLANNING PROCESS THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHETHER OR NOT
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT GAPS WHERE
WE NEED MANY MORE MONEY I CAN'T
TELL YOU RIGHT NOW.
IF I NEED MORE MONEY OR IF WE IF
WE HAVE ENUGH MONEY IS JUST NOT
POSSIBLE AT THE STAGE WHERE
WE'RE AT WE WILL NOT GET DOWN TO
THAT LEVEL UNTIL WE'VE.
FINISHED REALLY IN PARTICULARLY
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
WORKSHOPS OVER THE SUMMER THAT'S
WHERE WE'LL FIND THOSE GAPS THAT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT AS IT STANDS
RIGHT NOW THE WHOLE INTENT.
AND PURPOSE OF THE ART P. IN AS
DEEP AS MENTIONED IS.
EVERYTHING I CAME BACK FROM OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
WHO PUT AND PROPOSALS THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO IDENTIFY WHAT TEIR
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLANS ARE GOING
TO BE FOR THE TOP SIX LANGUAGES
AND THEIR REGION -- NOT ALL OF
THEM DID THAT SO NOW TO COMBAT
UPON US WITHIN THE CENSUS OFFICE
AND OUR REGIONAL PROGRAM
MANAGERS TO TO TAKE WHAT THEY
STARTED.
AND N MOLD
NEEDED TO BE WHICH IS TAKE THEIR
DOLLARS AND MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO THE
LOCATIONS. FOR A FOR PROVIDING
THAT LEVEL OF LANGUAGE ACCESS
ASSISTANCE AND THOSE LOW IN
THOSE AREAS WHERE THOSE
QUESTIONNAIRE SYSTEM CENTERS.
NEED TO BE SUB THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING AS WE FINALIZE
STRATEGIC PLANS AND THEN AS WE
HEAD INTO THE IMPLEMENTATION WE
GET INTO MORE GRANULAR DETAIL
WHEN WHEN WE KNOW THIS THEN PUT
WHEN WILL YOU FINISH THIS IS
SAID.
IN JULY INTIMIDATION LANNING
WORKSHOPS YES WE'RE DOING
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN OR
TWENTY EIGHT OF THEM.
COMMON THERE ARE HAVE DATA DAY
LONG WORKSHOPS AND SO THEY GO
THROUGH SEPTEMBER JUST BECAUSE
WE CAN'T DO THEM ONE DAY AT ONE
OR THE OTHER BECAUSE OF TRAVEL.
OKAY WORKSHOPS ARE GREAT BUT
WHEN WILL WE KNOW WHAT THE GAP
IS ARE WE DONE I MEAN WE DON'T
HAVE A GAP THAT'S GREAT.
TO IMPLEMENTATION PLANS OR DO IN
ORDER FOR THE CONTRACTORS TO GET
THEIR REST THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
DOLLARS -- WEDNESDAY OCTOBER
FIRST AND OCTOBER FIFTEENTH AND
SO THAT'S ONE WHAT WE'LL BE
DOING THE GAP WE'RE DOING THE
GAP ANALYSIS AS WE GO SOME
REGIONS ARE FURTHER ALONG SOME.
REGIONS CAN ACTUALLY IDENTIFY
HOW MUCH THEY'RE CBO'S ARE GONNA
SPEND PER PERSON.
OKAY SAID UNTO OVER -- SO
BASICALLY BY MID OCTOBER.
WHAT THE HAVE THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS IN?
AND IF YOU DEBT IF I GAPS WE
SHOULD BE IDENTIFYING GAPS ALONG
THE WAY RIGHT SO THEY'RE THERE
FOR THEIR SPREAD OUT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE SUMMER MONTHS SO
RIGHT BE WILL BE HITTING EACH
REGION AND WAVES AND STARTING
WITH OKAY.
AWAY DOWNTURN STATES.
I THINK LA IS PROBABLY THE LAST
ONE SO.
SO SO YOU WILL BE ABLE TO REPORT
BACK TO US BY MID OCTOBER THE
STATUS.
OF LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR THE
CENSUS IN CALIFORNIA.
WELL WE CAN REPORT BACK ON A
ROLLING BASIS AS WE CLOSE OUT ON
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS FOR VERY
OKAY BUT WE'VE BUT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE FOR THE WHOLE STATE
WE SHOULD COMPLETE THAT BY MID
OCTOBER.
YEAH YES SHOULD AND THOSE
COUNTIES IN A CBO'S CAN COME AND
TESTIFY TO THE WET WEATHER
MISSING.
A AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HELP
THEM FILL [inaudible]
TO OKAY.
IT'S JUST ONE SOME DEADLINES.
OKAY WE MAY FIGHT WE WILL TRY I
WANNA OF WELL WE CERTAINLY WOULD
APPRECIATE A ROLLING UPDATE
CERTAINLY WOULD.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT OUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE.
BECAUSE IN CASE WE DO NEED TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS.
ARE WE NEED RESOURCES OR
WHATEVER ELSE NOT TO SAY.
A LOT OF THE OF THE CHURCH.
HAVE THOSE TYPE THE DISK
DISCUSSIONS AT ANY NUYS THE
BUDGET IS -- COMING TOGETHER ON
WHAT ARE SOME TYPE OF
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE COULD
POSSIBLY -- PUT INTO PLACE WE
NEED TO HAVE GAP COVERAGE OKAY
NOW IS AGAIN I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM SOME OF THE COUNTIES AND
THE CBO'S THAT -- THAT YEAH THEY
FELT LIKE THAT THEY WE'RE NOT
THE EXPECTATIONS WERE NOT CLEAR
SO I THINK THAT I'M HOPING THAT
THAT WILL GET RESOLVED AS WELL.
THAT'S A YES OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- QUESTION SIT AT
YOUR SYSTEM MEMORY MISS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IN SOME OF OUR
RESEARCHERS YOU'RE DOING IT AND
REACHING OUT A LOT ABOUT THE
COUNTIES IN THE CITY'S BEING
ABLE COME FORWARD.
WHAT ARE YOU ALSO REACHING OUT --
TO TRAVEL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO GET THEIR INPUT OF
HOW BEST TO MAKE SURE THE CENSUS
IS BEING DONE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES ALSO.
YES OF LAST YEAR WE HELD.
THREE LESTER THREE TRIBAL
CONSULTATIONS NORTH SOUTH AND
CENTRAL -- TO GET THEIR INPUT
ABOUT WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
ENGAGE THEM WE HAVE A TROUBLE --
UGH A TRIBAL LAYS SOMEONE AND
DOING ADDITIONAL THREE OF
TROUBLE CONSULTATIONS LATER I
WOULD SAY.
SEPTEMBER OCTOBER NOVEMBER I'D
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE CALENDAR --
BUT WE'RE ALSO AND ENGAGING
TROUBLE GOVERNMENT'S WE'VE ALSO
FUNDED -- CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN VOTES PROJECT -- FORTY
THOUSAND TO DO STATEWIDE
OUTREACH AND ALSO -- CALIFORNIA
INDIAN MANPOWER CORPORATION
LORETTA SANCHEZ ALSO A FORTY
THOUSAND GRANTS TO HELP DO
STATEWIDE OUTREACH USING THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE IN
THEIR THE BRING IN THAT DATA
BACK I GUESS AS FAR AS THE THE
THE CHAIRS ASKING TO AS FAR AS
BRINGING THAT BACK WHILE.
THINGS ARE BEING ROLLED OUT ARE
WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET AN
UPDATE AS FAR AS A OUR REGION
MAYBE SOME AREAS THAT WERE
MISSING.
WITHIN THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ALSO.
I THINK SO WHERE DID DEVELOPING
IN THIS IS THE OF THE TECHNOLOGY
PIECE THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE IN
200-020-0010 -- IT'S OUR
STATEWIDE OUTREACH AND RAPID
DEPLOYMENT ON WE'RE PARTNERING --
WITH A ORGANIZATION YOU GUYS ARE
PROBABLY ALL FAMILIAR WITH
HAVING RUN CAMPAIGNS -- PDI TO
BE ABLE TO COLLECT THAT DATA TO
ACTUALLY SEE.
ARE THE KNOCKING ON DOORS DID
THEY GO TO AN EVENT HOW MANY
PEOPLE THAT THEY TOUCH KNOW WHAT
MEETINGS WHERE WERE THEY AND
THEN TO BE ABLE TO MAP WHERE
THEY ARE BECAUSE AGAIN WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE WHOLE MAP JUST
NOT JUST A DISTRICT. TO TRY TO
MEASURE ARE WE LOW IS THAT WILL
ALLOW YOU KNOW DO WE NOT GET
ENOUGH FEEDBACK AND THEN WHEN
THE ACTUAL RESPONSE TIME COMES
FROM.
MARCH FIFTEENTH THROUGH JULY
FIFTEENTH WATCHING SELF RESPONSE
RATES FROM THE US CENSUS BUREAU
TO SEE OKAY THIS IS WHERE WE
INVEST OUR DOLLARS IS WHERE
THEY'RE DOING EVENTS.
IS THE RESPONSE LOW OR HIGH AND
DO WE NEED TO INCREASE YOU KNOW
FOCUSED OUT REGION THAT AREA
DURING THE RESPONSE TIME.
SO WE'RE HOPING TO START START
TO IMPLEMENT THE SUMMER THAT
THAT TECHNOLOGY PIECE BILL NOTED
THAT SOME AN AREA OF THE HARD TO
COUNT.
AND WE HEARD EARLIER ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL GAPS AND LOOKING
TOWARDS -- SOME OF THOSE
FINANCIAL -- AREAS THAT ARE
THERE AND AND WHERE THOSE GAPS
ARE AT LOOKING AT SOME PRIVATE
FUNDING IN THOSE THINGS BUT I
THINK STILL WE SEE THE THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE NUCLEUS
THERE TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
GETTING ADEQUATE COUNT.
IN TROUBLE -- GOVERNMENT SO WHEN
HE DOES COME BACK TO THIS --
JOINT SELECT COMMITTEE HAD BE
INTERESTING TO HEAR FROM THOSE
FROM THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY TO TO TESTIFY AS FAR
AS WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT WHAT
IS IT.
A B. GRADE AND I MISTER WHEN WE
COME BACK THE CONTRACTORS THAT
WE'VE ENGAGED WOULD HAVE A GOOD
PLAN -- IN TERMS OF MEDIA I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE WIDE
MEDIA ARE A FEW WILL BE AWARDED
TOLD JUNE WHAT'S IS THAT IS.
IN IN THE PLAN THAT'S GOING TO
COME OUT IN MAY.
CAN YOU CAN YOU MAYBE SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT THIS IS THE SCOPE OF
THE PLAN IS IT GOING TO DEAL
WITH MEDIA.
IS OR IS IT JUST FOCUSED ON THE
COUNTIES IN THE A CBO'S -- SO
WHAT WHAT.
IMPACT ACTUALLY THAT I BELIEVE
THE THE THE THE LANGUAGE FAILS
THAT'S COME OUT BEFORE THIS
HEARING THAT'S WHAT WE TIME THE
HEARING TO BE ACTUALLY AFTER.
THE PLAN CAME OUT CLEAR THE PLAN
IS NOT YET ALTID STILL COUPLE
WEEKS OUT HE SPEAKS TO THE SCOPE
OF THE A PLAN THAT WE SHOULD
DISSIPATE -- SEEING IN ON MAY
SEVENTEENTH.
RIGHT SO THE MEAT WHILE THE THE
MEDIA OR P. WE JUST COULD CLOSED
pA NUMBER OF RESPONSES AND SO
WE'RE BEGINNING OUR EVALUATION
EVALUATION PROCESS.
ON THAT BUT THE SKIPPER THERE IF
YOU HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT LATELY
BUT IT DOES INCLUDE BOTH A SORT
OF OVERALL STRATEGIC.
OVERVIEW FOR COMMUNICATIONS
INCLUDES -- CONNECTING WITH
EARNED MEDIA IT INCLUDES
CONNECTING WITH ALL OF OUR
CONTRACTORS TO COURTNEY WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WE'VE HEARD FROM
SOME COUNTIES THAT THEY WANT TO
FOCUS ON MEDIA -- IT FOCUSES ON
BRANDING I MEAN IT HAS THE WHOLE.
LIKE KITCHEN SINK FULL OF STUFF
THAT THEY'LL BE DOING -- TO
CREATE THAT SURROUND SOUND BUT
FOR ME.
THE GOAL FOR OUR COMMUNICATIONS
PLAN OR MEDIA PLAN IS TO DRIVE
PEOPLE TO THIS QUESTION --
ASSISTANCE CENTERS TO DRIVE THEM
TO EITHER SELF RESPOND ON THEIR
PHONES ARE ON THEIR COMPUTERS OR
TO DRIVE THEM TO AREAS WHERE
THEY CAN GET THE HELP SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN.
TWENTY TEN AND IN -- TWO
THOUSAND A LOT OF THE JUST TAKE
IN THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY THEY HAD QUESTION YOUR
SYSTEM CENTERS THEY DID OF
THROUGH -- CALIFORNIA BIKE MEDIA
WE DID ONE PAGE YOU KNOW HUGE
INSERTS IN THEIR PUBLICATIONS
WHERE THEY PUT.
HERE'S THE LOCATION OF IT HERE
THE HOURS THAT THEY'RE OPEN AND
WE DROPPED HIM OFF AT ALL AT THE
CHURCHES.
OF IN OTHER AREAS WHERE PEOPLE
GET THEM WE EXPECT OTHER ETHNIC
MEDIA TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE
UP QUESTION YOUR ASSISTANCE
CENTERS THAT ARE YOU TO RUN BY
THE CBO IS OF THE COUNTIES.
INSERTED INTO THAT ETHIC MEDIA
SO PEOPLE KNOW WHERE TO GO AND
THAT'S PART OF YOUR V. D. R. E.
YES OKAY AND AND ACTUALLY THE
OTHER PART THE QUESTION WHICH
YOU HAVE ANSWERED YET IS SO FOR
THE MAY SEVENTEENTH LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN THE ONE THAT WE WERE
EXPECTING YET. FOR THIS HEARING.
WHAT IS THE SCOPE OF THAT
PARTICULAR -- REPORT GOING TO
ENCOMPASSES IT DOES INCLUDE MEET
THE LANGUAGE ASPECT OF MEDIA AS
IT JUST FOCUSED ON THE COUNTIES
IN THE A CBO ACTIVITIES.
CAN JUST SPEAK TO WHAT WE SHOULD
BE EXPECTING ON MAY SEVENTEENTH
IN TERMS OF WHAT WILL. TO EXPECT
IN THAT DOCUMENT I REALIZE THE
DETAILS ARE STILL BEING WORKED
OUT THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT OUT YET
BUT WHAT WHAT'S THE SCOPE OF
THAT PARTICULAR DOCUMENT THE
FOCUS WILL BE ON OUR CONTRACTORS
THAT'S THE MEDIA -- CONTRACT IS
STILL OUT FOR BID WE WANT TO
WAIT TILL THAT COMES IN AND THEN
WILL PROVIDE THAT SIMPLY TO THEM
BECAUSE IT'S ONE CONTRACTOR.
BUT WE DIDN'T WANT TO HOLD THAT
UP ALL IN TERMS OF THE COUNTY IN
THE C. B. AS IN THE CBO.
SO THAT MAY SEVENTEENTH LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLANS JUST FOCUSED ON THE
THE CBO'S AND COUNTIES OR THE
GROUND PART OF THE ACTIVITIES
OKAY.
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION IS
IS THAT -- SO I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT THE THE TRIGGER.
LANGUAGES HOWEVER I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT -- LEAST OUTSIDE OF LA
COUNTY EVEN WITH LA COUNTY WERE
AT 96% IT'S ONE EIGHT NINETY ONE
POINT 3% SO THAT'S STILL A LOT
OF PEOPLE GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S A
BIG STATE WHO STILL AREN'T
COVERED.
ARE THERE ANY EXPECTATIONS THAT.
ARE A C. B. AS DO ANYTHING TO
TRY TO COVER THAT REMAINING NINE
PERCENT'S.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO BRIDGE THE
GAP -- ON ON THAT THINKING ABOUT
SOME ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES -- TO
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
SO I THINK THAT WE JUST YOU HAVE
TO LOOK CLOSER THE DATA WHAT ARE
THOSE ACTUAL LANGUAGES TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ARE THE IN ROADS
BECAUSE SOME OF THEM ARE KIND OF
LIKE SWISS GERMAN AND SO THOSE
ONES YOU COULD PROBABLY.
YOU KNOW THE WAY I SEE THE SOME
OF THOSE LANGUAGES ARE GOING TO
BE HIT NOT SPECIFICALLY THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS THEY MAYBE HAD
THROUGH SECTOR OUT REACH MAYBE
HIT THERE ARE K. THROUGH TWELVE
OR EDUCATIONAL AVERAGE.
THE BABY HAD THROUGH OUR
STATEWIDE OUTREACH SO.
BUT WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE.
TWO OKAY WELL I I HOPE THAT THIS
ITEM BE THERE MAY BE ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGIES OTHER THAN SIMPLY
PROVIDING GET OUT THAT LANGUAGE
IT CETERA WHEN YOU LOOK AT BUT I
HOPE THAT THERE IS A STRATEGY AN
EXPECTATION THAT THERE SOME FORM
OF OUT REACH. TO THOSE
POPULATIONS BECAUSE OF THE RACE
BASICALLY YOU'VE WRITTEN OFF
TRYING TO GET ABOUT 9% OR EIGHT
EIGHT POINT. 7% OF THOSE PEOPLE
IN THOSE INDIVIDUALS NOT
HOUSEHOLDS SO WE'RE NOT SURE IF
THERE'S A HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD THAT
MAY SPEAK A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE
OR ENGLISH.
SO THAT THE LIMITATIONS OF THE
DATA -- THAT WE HAVE TO DIG
DEEPER IN DEBT AND I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT SOMETIMES WELL
CERTAINLY ENGLISH'S SERVE THE
PRIMARY LANGUAGE AND AND THIS.
STATE SOME SOME OF THE OTHER
LANGUAGES DEPENDING FOR EXAMPLE
AND IF IT COULD BE THAT THEY MAY
ACTUALLY NO NOT A T. I. LANGUAGE.
THAT THAT MAY BE THE LINKING
LANGUAGE SHOULD NOT ALWAYS
ENGLISH IS BEING THE LANGUAGE MY
MY DRIVE PEOPLE TO GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THE US CENSUS WILL BE
IN SOME OTHER LANGUAGES SO.
YES -- SUMMER READY JONES SAWYER.
HI IN IT.
ANGIE YOU BROUGHT UP
[inaudible]
THE COMMUNICATION -- ASPECT IN
AND AND I'M TRYING TO GET A GET
A FEELING OF HOW FLEXIBLE THAT
IS.
IN THAT ARE PROBABLY THE BEST
WAY TO DO THIS JUST BY EXAMPLE --
YES YOU MAY BE WORKING WITH THE
LOS ANGELES SENTINEL WHICH IS
AFTER AMERICAN NEWSPAPER IN LOS
ANGELES -- AND YES THEY HAVE A
REGULAR CIRCULATION BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE -- SOME CALLED CASE TO
SEOUL WHICH HAS ABOUT A HALF A
MILLION AFTER AMERICANS MANY OF
WHOM ARE IN MISS CALM WATERS
DISTRICT -- FROM MY DISTRICT
THAT SHOW UP -- BUT IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE DRIVING HIM. TO A
CERTAIN PLACE AS OPPOSED.
TO YOU NOW HAVE A HALF A MILLION
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN ONE SPOT.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO TELL THEM
LEAVE HERE. TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE
TO DO THE SENSES WHEN YOU COULD
HAVE A CAPTURED GROUP OF PEOPLE
RIGHT THERE.
AND THEN HAVE CENTS WHATEVER
THESE PEOPLE CALL THERE TO
ACTUALLY DO THAT AS THIS.
MEDIA PLAN THAT THAT FLEXIBLE
ROBUST ENOUGH OR IS IT.
YOU HAVE TO DO AN AT AND THAT'S
IT ARE YOU HAVE. TO WEBSITE OR
pAND YOU CAN'T.
SO THE THE SITES WE HAVE BEFORE
IS AT THE RIGHT PLACE AT THE
RIGHT TIME BY THE RIGHT PEOPLE
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO GO
TO A BRICKS AND MORTAR IT MEANS
WE DID SOCCER TOURNAMENTS.
WE DID YOU KNOW FOOTBALL GAMES
WE DID WHAT A YOU KNOW.
OF FESTIVALS THE VIETNAMESE YOU
KNOW FAST BALLS SO ARE CBO'S ARE
GOING TO AS AND THEY CAN FILL IT
OUT YOU CAN BRING A CELL ON
WHEELS TO FILL THESE THINGS OUT
TO HELP THAT.
SO NO ABSOLUTELY NOT EVEN THE
MEDIA BUT EVEN THE CBO'S ARE IN
TERMS OF THAT SORT OF SECOND LEG
OF DOING EVENTS AND TELL HOLES
AND GOING.
WHERE THE PEOPLE ARE IT'S ABOUT
BRING IT TO WHERE THEY ARE
WHETHER THAT'S IN A HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITY IN A COMMUNITY
CENTER WE'RE GOING TO THE THIS
WONDERFUL EVENT AND SOUNDS LIKE
WHERE PEOPLE GOING TO BE?
AND MAKING SURE PEOPLE GO OUT
AND MASS AND ARE ABLE TO GET
PEOPLE TO RESPOND SO ABSOLUTELY
SAID IN A BOOTH OR PAY FOR BOOKS
AND ALL OF THAT IS PART OF IT
OKAY.
THE IN PERSON WE'DLOVE TO HEAR
AN INTO MY DISTRICT THERE'S
FESTIVALS ALL OVER THE PLACE OF
WHAT I SEE A BIG FERRIS WHEELS
LIKE.
JUST SEVERAL TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
SHOWING UP I WOULD HOPE WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO COORDINATE WITH THAT
THIS.
IS ESPECIALLY THE LATINO PART OF
MY DISTRICT WHICH IS HUGE AND
OPEN A LOT OF WAYS AND SO THAT'S
BEEN ONE OF MY MAIN.
PROBLEMS THAT WE BECOME SO
STATIC AND WHAT WE DO THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING OUT OF
BOXES GOOD TO HEAR YEAH WE WANT
TO BE AS FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE
AND GO OVER THERE.
OKAY CENTER I'M BURKE AND AND SO
ON AND AND I REALIZE A SOUND
LIKE A BIT OF A BROKEN RECORD
BUT YOU MENTIONED THE MEDIA
STRATEGY.
SO CAN YOU GIVE US AN EXAMPLE OF
THE METRICS IN THE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT WILL BE LOOKING
FORWARD.
TO ASSESS THE EFFICACY OF THE
MEDIA STRATEGY.
THOUGH BECAUSE IT'S OUT TO BID
RIGHT NOW I'D RATHER NOT COMMENT
ON THAT -- BUT I THINK I'M NOT A
MEDIA SPECIALIST BUT I WOULD
ASSUME IMPRESSIONS LOOKING AT
WHERE THEY'RE PUTTING OUT THERE --
ADVERTISING AFTER USING SOCIAL
MEDIA CERTAINLY HAS REALLY GREAT --
YOU KNOW MEASUREMENTS -- BUT THE
MEASUREMENTS WERE USING IN TERMS
OF LIKE IN PERSON -- IS MORE
LIKE THE SORT OF PD I AB OF
KNOWING WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
SO ON MEDIA I'M GOING TO KIND OF
HOLD OFF ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK
WE MIGHT BE DOING A A MEETING
HER WILL HAVE MUCH MORE --
BACKGROUND ON WHAT THE NEW TOOLS
ARE IN TERMS OF MEASURING -- GET
A RADIO [inaudible]
PAPER.
SOCIAL MEDIA SO WHEN WHEN WE DO
THE R. F. P. ARE WE ASKING THE
RESPONDENTS TO PROVIDE THEIR OWN
WHICH IS OKAY THEIR OWN METRICS
AN ORAL PERFORMANCE MEASURES IN
THEIR OWN.
WHAT WHATEVER?
ANALYSES OF OF EFFICACY OR WE
PROVIDING THEM WE WANT TO SEE
YOU DO THE FOLLOWING HOW'S THAT
WORKING.
I MIGHT HAVE TO LOOK AT THE RP
CLOSELY WASN'T ON THAT ONE BUT I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT LIKE A
ELECTION WE 1100%.
SO BELOW I WILL HAT JUST I JUST
ASKED THAT QUESTION EVERY TIME
WE COME TO THE SUBJECT IS HOW DO
WE MEASURE.
WHAT ARE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
WHAT OUR METRICS HOW DO WE
FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY WERE BEING
EFFICIENT SELF SO ARMY WITH ITS
WITH VOTERS WITH THE LOW
PREVENTS THE VOTERS HOW MANY
TIMES YOU HAVE TO HAVE THEM FIVE
TIMES RATE?
BUT WE DON'T KNOW IS BECAUSE
THIS HAPPENS EVERY TEN YEARS AND
WE DIDN'T COLLECT THIS TYPE OF
DATA IN TWENTY TEN IS.
HOW MANY TIMES YOU HAVE TO TOUCH
A VERY HARD TO COUNT PERSON THE
HAS ALL THESE DIFFERENT
VARIABLES RATE?
CAPS OF THREE TIMES FIVE TIMES
TEN TIMES SO THAT'S THE TYPE OF
THING IS WE DON'T HAVE.
DATA FROM TWO THOUSAND TEN OR
TWO THOUSAND THAT SHOWS THAT AND
I'M HOPING THAT.
WE'RE PUTTING THESE COLLECTIONS
IN PLACE AND THAT OUR PARTNERS
WILL BE ABLE TO COLLECT THE DATA
TO GIVE US SOME INDICATION.
THAT YOU KNOW IF WE HIT THIS
AREA SO MANY TIMES THAT MAYBE IT
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY RESPONDED AND WE'LL SEE THE
RESPONSE RATE FROM THE CENSUS
BUREAU BUT WITHOUT THAT SORT OF
YOU KNOW.
DATA FROM TEN YEARS AGO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE RIVER AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
HI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APOLOGIZE
THERE ATTENDED LATE -- THE THING
THAT CAME TO MIND ALL OF A
SUDDEN WAS THAT WE HAVE MANY
PEOPLE THEIR LIVES ILLITERATE.
AND THEY ARE NOT I DON'T SEE
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO HOW WE'RE
GOING TO TOUCH THOSE.
I LEARNED THIS THE HARD WAY
WORKING WITH HOUSING AUTHORITIES
TRYING TO GET INFORMATION GET
PEOPLE TO GO TO MEETINGS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS.
AND WE DIDN'T GETTING ATTENDANCE
AND REALIZED MANY PEOPLE DON'T
EVEN READ.
ENGLISH OR IN THEIR OWN NATIVE
LANGUAGE SO IS THERE ANYTHING IN
THIS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON AND I KNOW THAT'S A
CHALLENGE BUT SO FOR SOME OF THE
INFOGRAPHICS I MEAN ARE ARE THE
WAYS THAT MANY OF OUR SOCIAL
SERVICES REACH OUT -- AND THEN
IN PERSON REMAIN ME WE TALKED
ABOUT FOLKS THAT DON'T WANT TO
ADMIT THAT THERE ARE PERHAPS THE
READING SKILLS ARE LOW -- AND
OFTEN YOU ASKED WOULD YOU RATHER
HAVE THIS IN WRITING WOULD YOU
LIKE SOMEBODY TO TALK WITH YOU
AND THAT'S KIND OF HOW.
THEY WOULD IDENTIFY SO WE'RE
HOPING AGAIN TO WORK WITH OUR
COMMITTEES GROUPS OR HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN THE AREAS AND
SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND LASTLY I'M COMMITTED TO HELP
WHATEVER MY DISTRICT OFFICES
COMMITTED TO HELP OUT WHICHEVER
WAY WE CAN TO HELP OVERCOME SO
THE BEARS ON THE LANGUAGE.
AND ARE WORKING WITH YOUR TEAM
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY IS THAT.
I THINK WE ALL OWE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO BE AT
THE TABLE TO HELP YOU OUT SO.
I'M ALL IN APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU THERE DRAWS A GOOD TO TALK
TO GET IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK -- I JUST
ONE IT'S NOT AS MUCH A QUESTION
AS IT IS A CONCERN -- THAT AS
YOU DO THE MEDIA PLAN IN
PARTICULAR -- I THINK -- IT'S
SAFE TO SAY THEY'LL PROBABLY BE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SOMEWHERE.
IN THAT -- OF INVESTED BY THE
STATE -- AND AS WE LOOK TO
LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION
ACCESS ESPECIALLY.
REALLY OUR MONEY HAS TO BE SPENT
IN THE HARD TO COUNT.
OF BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
YOU'RE RIGHT HOW MANY --
EVERYONE ELSE WILL NEED HOW MANY
REMINDERS BUT THE HARD TO COUNT
IS OUR DIFFICULTY AND LA COUNTY
HAS THE LARGEST HARD TO COUNT.
AND NOT TO MENTION THE HEART
THAT TRANSLATES INTO THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS OF HARD TO COME.
BUT SPECIFICALLY WITH THE MEDIA --
I JUST WANT.
TO RAISE MY CONCERN THAT I'VE
SEEN.
IN VARIOUS VENUES AND PROGRAMS --
THAT THE MONEY GOES [inaudible]
TO ONE SORT OF COMPANY OR
SOMEBODY IN CHARGE OF THAT. TO
DOLE IT OUT -- AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK WE LOSE -- THAT MONEY
GOING TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT.
MOST NEED IT AND IT'S KIND OF
SIMILAR TO SENATOR UMBERG IS IF
WE'RE NOT CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE
EXPECT FROM THEM.
AND I KNOW BECAUSE YOU HAVE SO
MUCH ON YOUR PLATE.
THAT -- YOU WOULDN'T GET INTO
THE WEEDS.
OF IT ARE BUT I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE LOSE IT AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'VE HAD LOTS OF PROBLEMS
IS.
THAT THAT REALLY THAT THE
RESOURCES REALLY DON'T GET DOWN.
INTO THOSE -- LOW RESOURCE OR NO
RESOURCE PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IT DOESN'T GET INTO
THE ETHNIC MEDIA THEY'RE NOT THE
FANCY.
YOU KNOW WELL KNOWN -- MEDIA ALL
OR IF THEY'RE YOU KNOW THEIR
THEY'RE HOMEGROWN SOMETIMES SO
IN THE SAME WAY THAT YOU HAVE
MADE A SPECIAL EFFORT TO REACH
OUT.
TO THE COMMUNITY BASED ON THE
AREA BASED ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE
THEIR TRUSTED.
THE ETHNIC MEDIA IS TRUSTED BY
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HARD TO
COUNT [inaudible]
UNLIKE ALLEGEDLY -- NEUTRAL YOU
KNOW OUTLETS MEDIA OUTLETS WHICH
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE SO NEUTRAL
BUT MEDIA OUT AT THE MEDIA
OUTLETS ARE TRULY.
TRUSTED RABIN ADVOCATES FOR
THEIR PARTICULAR COMMUNITY SO.
I'M GIVING THIS LONG ABOUT WAY
OF JUST URGING YOU TO EXPECT
MORE.
AND TO DEMAND MORE FROM HOWEVER
THOSE RESOURCES -- FOR YOU KNOW
FOR IT THE MEDIA HOWEVER THEY GO
OUT WE'VE GOT A PUSH AND
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO BE.
RESPONSIBLE FOR PUSHING THAT
DOWN INTO THESE COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU AND I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN -- A CONTINUE TO BE
EVEN AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
APPOINTED FOR ETHNIC MEDIA --
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THEY KNOW.
THEIR COMMUNITIES BEST NOT EVEN
LOOKING AT WHAT THE US CENSUS
BUREAU WILL SEND US IN TERMS OF
ADS FOR LIKE FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY I CAN SHOW
YOU PICTURES OF WHAT THEY SENT
IT WAS.
DID NOT LOOK LIKE.
WHAT THE YUROK TRIBE WOULD LOOK
AT YOU KNOW LOOK LIKE SOUTH
DAKOTA SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
HERE -- AND AND TRULY COMMITTED
TO AT THE MEDIA AND IT'S EVEN
MORE HELPFUL AND THAT WE WILL
PUSH THAT DOWN FOR ME TO HEAR
FROM YOU WHO ARE THOSE TRUSTED.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES ARE SO SMALL I
REMEMBER IN TWO THOUSAND I GOT
ON IT TONGUE IN TALK SHOW THIS
THE COMBINE A WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW NINETY MINUTES ON
SUNDAY EVERY THIRD SUNDAY COME
TALK TO US RATE AND IT DIDN'T
HAVE PROBABLY THE NIELSEN SHARE
THAT EVERY ELSE WOULD HAVE.
BUT WE WENT ON THERE AND WE WERE
ABLE TO REACH THAT COMMUNITY IN
THAT VERY MIGRATORY GET AWAY SO
WE TALK ABOUT MULTI MEDIA MULTI
ETHNIC AND MICROTECH AT SO I
REALLY.
APPRECIATE THAT AND WOULD LOVE
TO HEAR.
FROM ALL YOUR OFFICES BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHO THOSE
OUTLETS ARE -- BECAUSE HE ANY
FIRM IS NOT GOING TO KNOW ALL OF
THEM SO.
THIRTIES WILL COMMENT.
IN OUR DISTRICT -- SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY FOUR WE PROBABLY
HAVE THE LARGEST -- NUMBER
WITHIN A SINGLE DISTRICT OR ONE
OF THE LARGE NUMBERS OF DIVERSE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER ON
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES SO
IT'S REALLY.
DIVERSE AND A SINGLE DISTRICT
GET TO KNOW.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY.
RIGHT WELL THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION WE LOOK FOR TO
FOLLOW UP I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
GONNA STAY FOR THE HEARING AND
THEN GIVE US A REFLECTION BACK
FROM THEIR NECKS SET OF
PANELISTS SO WE HAVE -- AS WELL
SO THANKS VERY MUCH RIGHT SO
IT'S WE HAVE OUR NEXT PANEL SAID
THE ADVOCATE INPUT ON RE
REACHING THE HARD TO COUNT WITH
THE ROBUST LANGUAGE ACCESS
STRATEGY WE HAVE -- JUST OF
BILLY Là.
DIRECTOR POLICY OF THE COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
SANTOSH SERENE SENTADA
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WELCOME
[inaudible]
YOU.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
SO I THINK -- OKAY.
THREE GOOD AFTERNOON AS CHAIRMAN
PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY.
I'M CENTER SYRIAN SANTANA AND
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WHICH
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
WE ARE COMMUNITY BASED CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION LOCATED IN
SAN FRANCISCO'S CHINATOWN.
AND SINCE OUR INCEPTION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE WE HAVE
WORKED ON EVERY DECENNIAL CENSUS
FOR THE PAST FIVE DECADES THAT
WORKS INCLUDES LAWSUITS FOR THE
AGAINST THE FEDERAL CENSUS
BUREAU.
ADVOCATING AT THE STATE LEVEL
FOR INCREASED CENSUS FUNDING AND
ACTUALLY DOING DIRECT OUT REACH
OUR TO OUR COMMUNITY FOR CENSUS.
ALL RELATED TO CENSUS HAS
REMAINED CONSTANT TO HELP
PRODUCE A FAIR AND ACCURATE
COUNT OF OUR HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES THAT SPEAK LITTLE TO
NO ENGLISH.
WE CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION ALONG WITH SEVERAL OTHER
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS GROUPS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS SUBMITTED
FOUR PAGES OF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
MARCH TWENTY SECONDS. TO THE
CENSUS STATE LEADERSHIP ON WHAT
WE THOUGHT WOULD MAKE A ROBUST.
MEANINGFUL AND SUBSTANTIVE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN FOR THOSE
OF OUR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT COMMUNITIES THIS WAS
IN RESPONSE TO THE DRAFT
DOCUMENTS THAT THE THE STATE
CENSUS OFFICE PUT OUT.
SO I DID PREPARE REMARKS BUT
GIVEN THAT OUR STATE CENSUS
DIRECTOR SHARED -- WHAT WOULD BE
IN THE SECONDITERATION IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND I WOULD LIKE -- TO
ADDRESS SOME OF MY QUESTIONS AND
SOME COMMENTS TO THAT -- SO.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT SHE'LL BE
STAYING SO SHE COULD.
RESPOND SO IN THE REVISED PLAN
ON THE TALKS ABOUT TRIGGERS AND
SO I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT.
WHETHER YOU HAVE NUMERICAL
TRIGGERS PERCENTAGE TRIGGERS A
NUMBER OF LANGUAGES THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO REQUIRE IN THE STATE'S
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN.
A DATA DRIVEN APPROACH IS NEVER
GOING TO HIT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE SMALL.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO HIT THE
SMALL SOUTHEAST IN SOUTHEAST
ASIAN COMMUNITIES IT'S NOT GOING
TO HIT.
OUR PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
LANGUAGES WHICH ACTUALLY HAS NO
LANGUAGE SUPPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL CENSUS -- AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO HIT THE NON WRITTEN
LANGUAGES THAT ARE SPOKEN IN OUR
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH OUR
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES.
SO.
THERE IT NEEDS TO BE A
BIFURCATED PLAN WHICH THE PLAN
ADDRESSES THE LARGER LANGUAGE
ACCESS GROUPS THAT HITS THESE
TRIGGERS AND THEN ANOTHER --
PLAN.
TO ADDRESS THE SMALLER GROUPS.
THE STATE'S LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN
SHOULD AFFIRM A COMMITMENT TO
THE SMALLER GROUPS AND PUT MONEY
BEHIND THAT AFFIRMATION AND MORE
DETAILS AROUND IT.
ARE THE SECOND THING I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON WAS.
YOU KNOW LAST WEEK.
THE SUPREME COURT TOOK UP THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
AND BY ALL REPORTS IT DIDN'T
LOOK GOOD FOR OUR COMMUNITY WITH
A FIVE FOUR LEANING.
THE STATE'S LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN
HAS TO BE NIMBLE AND FLEXIBLE.
TO ADDRESS IF A CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION IS ON THE CENSUS
BECAUSE WE AS A COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE
TO BE NIMBLE AND FLEXIBLE WHAT
IS THAT CONTINGENCY PLAN LOOK
LIKE FROM LANGUAGE ACCESS --
THIRD.
IN MANY WAYS ARE WE ARE IN A
HISTORIC MOMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE OF THOSE WAYS IS WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS AT OUR STATE'S BORDERS.
SO WE HAVE A LARGE INFLUX OF
REFUGEES ARE COMING TO
CALIFORNIA AND IF THEY'RE HERE
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THEY
SHOULD BE COUNTED.
AND THEY SHOULD BE COUNTED AND
OUTREACH TO IN THEIR LANGUAGE --
AND I WOULD JUST ASK THAT TO THE
STATE CENSUS OFFICE WORK WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THAT HAS A NEW COMERS PROGRAM
THAT HAS DATA REGARDING WHAT
THOSE LANGUAGES ARE [inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW I'M I'M HAPPY TO
SEE THAT THE PLAN WILL BE OUT ON
THE SEVENTEENTH.
SO WE COULD GIVE FURTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK IS -- IS
NEEDED IS WHILE [inaudible]
ARE A THEY RECOGNIZE THAT WE THE
FEEDBACK IN TEAMS WAS A TO
TRANSITION FROM STANDARDS TO AN
OPERATIONAL PLAN.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
SEE THAT THANK YOU IN.
IN THE M. MAY SEVENTEENTH AND SO
SOME OF THE THINGS WE'D LIKE TO
SEE IS WHICH LANGUAGE GROUPS
WILL BE TARGETED THE AMOUNT THAT
WILL BE SPENT ON THAT LANGUAGE
OF THOSE LANGUAGE GROUPS.
AND THE RECOMMENDED AND APPROVED
METHODS FOR REACHING THESE
GROUPS THE PLAN SHOULD STATE
WHAT QUALIFIES AS A LANGUAGE
ACCESS EXPENSE AND THERE MUST BE
A MECHANISM FOR PARTNERS ALL THE
STATE PARTNERS TO TRACK AND
REFLECT.
HOW THEY ARE SPENDING THOSE
DOLLARS IN EACH GROUP I THINK IT
GETS TO THE ISSUE OF METRICS AND
COUNTING AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S TRANSPARENCY AND -- THAT
THESE DOLLARS ARE GOING TO WHERE
THEY NEED AND THAT THE GAPS ARE
REALLY BEING FELT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
AND THANK YOU -- AMERICANS
JOSEPH JENNA DR POLICY NOT
BECAUSE IT WOULD CHIRLA THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE MEGAN RICE --
WE GENERALLY WHEN I ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE SENT US IN REGARDS
TO LANGUAGE ACCESS RESPONSE
CHIRLA IS A NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS FOUNDED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX ADVANCE SAID
THE HUMAN CIVIL RIGHTS OF
IMMIGRANTS JILL HAS EIGHT
OFFICES ACROSS THE STATE FROM
LOS ANGELES DEPARTED BILLS
SUMMER GUARDINO IN SACRAMENTO
AND ALSO WE HAVE A NATIONAL
OFFICE.
POLICY OFFICE IN WASHINGTON DC
FIRST ELECTED REELECTED TAKE
THAT THEY LEADERSHIP OF THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY -- AND THIS
COMMITTEE FOR MOVING FOR US TO
RELEASE TO PLANNING AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE READY FOR THE
CENSUS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE STEPS ARE
CRITICAL GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY
STEPPING BACK.
AND MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
HER TO GO COMMUNITIES TO
ACTUALLY ACCOUNT LASTLY ALSO
REALIZING THAT CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS PRIMARY ELECTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE DOING THE SAME TIME.
SO MANY OTHER ANY STATIONS ARE
DOING GEO TV WORK WE'LL BE DOING
ALSO.
GET OUT OF THE ACCOUNT AB
EFFORTS SETTING THIS IS A THIS
HEARING SEE A PARTICLE IMPORTANT.
WE ALREADY CHIRLA ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS ONE
COMMUNITY IN REGARDS TO TO THE
FEARS THAT THEY HAVE FIRST OUR
OUR HOTLINE IS GETTING
pSIGNIFICANT I QUESTIONS NOT ONLY
FROM CALIFORNIA BUT IT ALSO.
OTHER STATES AS RELATES TO WHAT
IS CITIZENSHIP QUESTION WILL
MEAN. TO THEM FURTHER MORE A FEW
DAYS OTHER EFFORTS BY THE
ADMINISTRATION S. RELEASED TO
PUBLIC CHARGE.
TRYING TO CHANGE HOW PEOPLE
BECOME LEGAL RESIDENTS LEGAL
PRIMARY RESIDENCE.
IN ADDITION TO INCREASE INTERIOR
ENFORCEMENT THAT IS INCREASING
THE FEAR OF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND REFUGEES.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO ENSURE THAT
I WE DO OUR PART TO THAT IN
THESE LAST YEARS WOULD BE PART
OF THE SENSES POLICY NETWORK.
I'M A A DIVERSE COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WORKING TO EDUCATE POLICYMAKERS
ABOUT MAKING INVESTMENT THE
WORDS THE SENSORS.
UP TO THAT IN THIS YEAR WE ALSO
MADE A REQUEST TO THE BUDGET I
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES TO CBO IS
A REQUIRES WAS OF NINETY THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
DIDN'T FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR THE
ONE THAT HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
CURRENTLY.
THIS PARTICULAR IMPORTANT GIVEN
THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING LANGUAGE
ACCESS AS OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
KEY ASPECTS OF THE CENSUS IS
THAT THE PLAN IN REGARDS TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS. TO THAT IN.
A LEASE FOR US WE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
WE HGHLIGHT THOSE THOSE
LANGUAGES THAT ARE ARE NOT
TRADITIONAL FOR FOR US IMMIGRANT
A REPUBLICAN ESPECIALLY THE
CENTER VALLEY WE SEE A NUMBER OF
LOW LITERACY IMMIGRANTS WHO WHAT
THEY THERE'S A STEAK MASSIVE
RELATES TO WHETHER NOT THEY COME
OUT AND SAY LIKE I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO READ.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO COMMUNICATE
AND SO THEREFORE WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A PLAN AB FOUR
DOES STOP FOR DOES LANGUAGES
ESPECIALLY THAT ACCOUNT -- FOR
FOR FOR INCLUDING A PADDLING
WHICH IS ARE NOT TRADITIONAL --
I'M IN ADDITION TO THAT.
WE ATTENDED I SEE YOUR LIST OF
WHAT ATTENDED THE AB COMPLETE
CAM COMEDIAN WHICH THE DRAFT ON
LANGUAGE ACCESS WAS RELEASED.
I WOULDPROVIDE SOME SOME INPUT
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
THE PLAN AS I GET ALLOWING
MYSELF WITH -- MY COLLEAGUE
SUMMONS THAT WE NEED MORE
DETAILS IN REGARDS TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND MORE
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES -- WE ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLANS A FILL THE GAP I'M
AT THE STATE BUT THAT ALSO AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR EXAMPLE HOW
TO ADDRESS.
THE NEEDS OF IMMIGRANTS AGAIN
THAT SPEAK ENGLISH -- BY THEY
SPEAK A DIALECT -- IN THESE
CASES THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
FURTHERMORE WE ALSO URGE THE
STATE.
I DO HAVE A PLAN THAT IS
FLEXIBLE TO COVER ANY LANGUAGES
ANY OTHER LANGUAGE OR DIALECT
WHOSE POPULATION MIGHT BE LOWER
BUT ELLIE P. MIGHT BE HIGHER AND
SO THAT THAT THAT THAT GOES INTO
THE SHOULD THE TRIGGER.
THAT IT HAS TO BE FLEXIBE ANY
AND HAS TO HAVE A DIFFERENT PLAN
FOR SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE -- THAT
AGAIN THAT ANY PLAN CONSIDERS
NOT RE LANGUAGES INCLUDING
DIALECTS AND A PM LANGUAGES --
IMMIGRANTS COME FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS INCLUDING
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT AND WE
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
THEM WHO ARE LOW LITERACY IS THE
QUESTION BECOMES WHAT IS THE
PLAN FOR THEM AS WELL.
IN REGARDS -- TO LANGUAGE ACCESS.
LASTLY WE MIGHT HAVE A PERFECT
PLAN OUT BUT HE CANNOT BE
IMPLEMENTED EITHER AT THE READ
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE OUT
ALLOCATED SO FOR US WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR STATEWIDE A REGIONAL
A CBO'S TO CARRY OUT.
THEIR LANGUAGE AND COMMUNICATION --
ACCESS PLAN WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- AC AB A CBO'S ARE
COMPENSATE.
WILL PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THOSE
CONTRACTORS IF THEY HAVE TO MEET
A SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AXIS
STRESSFUL OTHERWISE I WILL NOT
BE IMPLEMENTED.
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE --
AND AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SO I EXT.
SO IT WAS SUPPOSE THAT --
CERTAINLY -- AND THEN WE ASK
THEM A QUESTION IN TERMS OF OKAY
WELL -- THE TRIGGERS RIGHT THERE
PEOPLE DON'T SPEAK THOSE
LANGUAGES THAT -- REACH THE
TRIGGER AND APPRECIATE YOU SAID
WELL WE SHOULD STILL FIND A WAY
TO DO IT.
CAN BE A LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT YOU PROPOSE -- HOW WE
GO ABOUT DOING IT WE HEARD FROM --
THE DIRECTOR THAT WILD TO MAYBE
OTHER STRATEGIES AND SO FORTH
BUT CAN YOU BABIES.
GIVE US SOME SUGGESTIONS --
SPECIFY HOW.
HOW DO WE APPROACH --
ESSENTIALLY -- THE VICE MUCH
SMALLER GROUPS IN TERMS OF IN
TERMS OF LANGUAGE ACCESS -- SO
THEY'RE NOT THEY SAID THEY DON'T
NEED TO TRIGGERED AND READ THE
NUMBER OR SAID WHAT WE STILL
NEED TO REACH OUT TO THEM I MEAN
I THINK CONCEPTUALLY WE ALL
AGREE.
HOW WOULD YOU GO ABOUT DOING
THAT HOW WOULD YOU PROPOSE GOING
ABOUT DOING IT WHAT KIND OF
THING SHOULD BE REQUIRING COUNTY
USERS THE CBO'S TO BE DOING OR
WHAT ARE HOW WOULD YOU THIS IT
WILL?
TELL US HOW TO DO IT WHAT WOULD
YOU TELL THEM.
WE'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAFF AND WE APPRECIATE
THEIR TIME AND EFFORT AND I DO
BELIEVE THE STATE CENSUS OUT
REACH STAFF -- ARE AWARE OF THE
SAME CHALLENGES AND I THINK ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT YOU GO ABOUT IT
IS ACTUALLY -- IS TO HAVE A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS -- I DON'T
KNOW IF STATE CENSUS HAS BROUGHT
FOLKS TOGETHER FOR THOSE KINDS
OF MEETINGS AND FOR THOSE KINDS
OF ISSUES TO BE DISCUSSED.
WELL IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE
KNOW WHO ARE THE GROUPS THAT
WORK WITH THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES.
UP IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
WHAT THOSE LANGUAGES ARE WHAT
ARE THE BEST WAYS TO REACH THEM
SOME OF A MERE HERE AND YOU'LL
HEAR FROM THEM -- WE HAVE SEE
RACH HERE WHO WORKS WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COMMUNITIES AND
THEY CAN SPEAK TO THOSE --
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT THOSE NEEDS
ARE.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT HIDDEN WE KNOW
THAT THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY THERE ARE NO.
THERE ARE NO LANGUAGE SUPPORTS
SO THESE ARE KNOWN ISSUES AND
KNOWN CHALLENGES AND I THINK IT
REALLY ACTUALLY INVOLVES A
CONVERSATION WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES ABOUT WHAT THOSE
LANGUAGE ACCESS.
BARRIERS ARE AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAYBE IT ISN'T A
TRIGGER MAYBE TO TRIGGER WITH
THE BIGGER -- ELLIE P.
COMMUNITIES AND MAYBE IT'S JUST.
WILL COUNT EVERYBODY IN THIS
POPULATION MAYBE IT'S LOOKING AT
THINGS IN IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY
SINCE BEEN HAVING A BIFURCATED
PLAN FOR THE BIGGER LET ELLIE P.
COMMUNITIES AND THEN THE MUCH
SMALLER ONES.
SO -- THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU THINK ABOUT.
OKAY WELL LET'S SEE.
SO -- HERE BY HER TO STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WHICH IS GREAT BUT I'M
NOT HEARING SPECIFIC APPROACH TO
HOW ARE.
AND AND I GUESS OKAY LIKE THOSE
OTHER QUESTION THEN.
NO CALIFORNIA VERY BIG STATE --
YOU KNOW LA COUNTY ALONE IS
BIGGER THAN MOST OTHERS THAN
MOST OF THE STATE AND THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY.
ALONE.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH LARGER FORTY TWO
OTHER STATES SO YOU WOULD TAKE
LA OUT RIGHT -- SO IS THIS
SOMETHING WE SAY STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IS A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
TAKES PLACE AT THE STATE LEVEL
WHICH COURSE WE HAVE A VERY
LARGE STATE OR IS THIS SOMETHING
WE HAVE REGIONAL A CBO'S IS A
SOMETHING WE EXPECT THE A CBO TO
DO SO THAT WE GET.
NOW AND EVEN SOME OF THE CEOS
ARE COVERING MULTIPLE COUNTIES
AND SO FORTH.
SO WHAT WHAT I MEAN TERMS OF
YOUR EXPECTATION ABOUT IS THIS --
IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE REACH
THESE MUCH SMALLER BECAUSE WE
START TALKING ABOUT PARTICULAR
OR LANGUAGES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PERHAPS MAYBE IT'S THE A%
CBO WHOSE FOCUSING ON THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT SHOULD BE
DOING THIS.
PURSES -- SO THE DAY.
WAY YOU PROPOSED WHAT DO YOU
SUGGEST.
WELL WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE DRAFT
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN.
THEY HAD STATEWIDE CBO'S ON THE
ROOF -- RESPONSIBLE FOR SPANISH
AND ENGLISH THEY HAD THE
REGIONALS ONLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
SIX LANGUAGES THEY HAD COUNTIES
MAKING A REASONABLE EFFORT.
I THINK THERE HAS TO BE SOME
COHESIVENESS ABOUT WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT.
WHO WHAT ARE THE TARGETED
LANGUAGES YOU HAVE THE STATE
PARTNERS?
HAVE THEM DETERMINE WHERE HAVE
THE SENSE STATE CENSUS MY
DETERMINE.
ARE THE REGION'S THE BETTER ONES
ARE THE COUNTIES THE BETTER ONES
ARE THE STATE WIDE CBO IS YOU
HAVE PARTNERS USE THEM AND AND
HAVE THERE BE SOME -- COHESION.
IDENTIFY THE LANGUAGES IDENTIFY
THE LANGUAGE GROUPS AND AND GO
FROM THERE [inaudible]
YES.
SUBSIDY FOR US IS BOTH FRIDAY IS
MAKING SURE MILLION ALIGN MYSELF
WITH MY COLLEAGUE GETTING SOME
OF THE COMMENTS BUT I THINK ALSO
IS VERY REGIONAL AS SERIOUS AS
THE A CBL HAVE TO HAVE SOME SORT
OF A GUIDE AS AS HE RELATES TO
THAT.
BUT MORE IMPORTANT HAVE TO HAVE
SOME RESOURCES THAN IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THE SOME OF THAT THAT
THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
I DO FOR US WE KNOW.
WE KEEP THAT THERE WAS THAT A
SOME.
I CLEAR EXPECTATIONS RELATES TO
WHAT A CBO WHO IS GOOD AT DOING
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE CANADIAN
WITH A STATEWIDE PARTNERS A
CIVILIZED LANGUAGE ACCESS.
THAT PLAN ARE GOING TO COME.
YOU KNOW COME BACK IN THE FUTURE
AND THAT IS GOING TO DETERMINE A
LITTLE BIT HOW TO BE CORNY BUT I
DO YOU FOR US THE IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF EIGHTIES.
HAVE CLEAR -- GUIDANCE FROM A
STATE PLAN IN RELAYED THAT TO A
CBO IS WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
REGIONALLY BUT THAT'S HOW IS
THAT GOING -- TO COMPLEMENT THIS
THEY WORK SETTING THE FACT THAT
THE FIRST RAP HAD A LOT OF WE
HAD A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
IT DID NOT ALLOW US TO DO
ESSENTIALLY COME A WITH A WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE
THERE WAS NOTHING TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO IN SOME ASPECTS.
OKAY.
SO -- SO I SEE DIRECTOR HERE I
GUESS WHEN YOU REFLECT SOUNDS
SOUNDS LIKE I'M HEARING A LOT OF
WE NEED CLEAR DIRECTION WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT -- AT AND
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING AT SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AND THEN I
GUESS. ONE HEARING FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AT LEAST THE DRAFT
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN WHATEVER
YOU SEEN SO FAR STILL RAISE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS AND IT WAS LACK
OF CLARITY IS TO OF THIS TO THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE AND I THINK THE
QUESTION WITH THE ANSWER BECOMES
LIKE WHAT'S THE OUTCOME OF THE
PLANT.
SO THAT WAS NOT NOT LOOK AT THE
OUTCOMES RIGHT SO YOU KNOW I
CALM YOU KNOW WHO WHO'S GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE DOES NOT COME OKAY.
BUT THE RIGHT HAVING MORE
MEETING THAT PLAN WOULD HAVE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE THE QUESTION
BUT OKAY YOU KNOW UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU KNOW ALSO THIS IS A
GOOD CONVERSATION -- BUT ALSO
GIVING CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE WAY LA
KIND IS LEADING THE WAY MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING A GOOD JOB
AND I THINK THIS CONVERSATION IS
TIMELY.
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL
MONTHS TO FIGURE THIS OUT SO I
DO WHEN I PROVIDE SOME -- SOME
CREDIT TODAY TO THE COMPLETE CAM
COMEDIAN AND AND THE EFFORTS OF
EVERYONE BUT I THINK OUR HOPE IS
THAT.
YOU KNOW HIS GIVEN THAT TAX THAT
WE SEE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE
H. SEEKING TO UNDERMINE THE
SENSES AND WE HAVE TO BE AT THE
STEPS AHEAD OF OF THOSE OF THOSE
WHO ONE ON THEIR MIND THEY
AFFECT.
OKAY OKAY.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION PRE ****.
KAY SO OUR NEXT PANEL IS
PERSPECTIVES FROM COUNTIES IN
COMMITTEE BASS ORGANIZATIONS WE
HAVE THIRTY A PARK MANAGER CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES.
THE COUNTY LARGER THAN FORTY TWO
STATES OKAY.
MAN DEEP SAYING A SAFE DIRECTOR
OF CHIKARA MOVEMENT AND JUST
COAL -- WITH DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT COMMUNICATIONS FOR
ORANGE COUNTY WELCOME.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
COUNTIES IN AC VEAS NOW YOU GET
TO SPEAK FOR YOURSELVES THE WHAT
YOU'RE EXPECTING WHAT YOU WERE
TOLD WHAT YOU EXPECTED TO DO
[inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BEHANAN
CHAIRMAN BERMAN TO MEMBERS OF
THE SENSES SELECT COMMITTEE AND
THE MANAGER. FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICE
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART TODAY'S
CONVERSATION ON INSURING
LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS.
THE COUNTY OF LA APPRECIATES THE
DEDICATED SUPPORT THAT THE STATE
IS DEMONSTRATED FOR LOCAL
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES AND
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
AS YOU RECOGNIZED REACHING OUR
ENTIRE STATE WHY POPULATION
ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION IN THIS
CRITICAL CENSUS EFFORT WILL BE
CHALLENGING.
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LEAVE ANY
POPULATION UNCOUNTED.
TODAY WE ARE HERE TO FOCUS ON
THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY NEARLY A
QUARTER OF OUR RESIDENTS.
ARE CHARACTERIZED HIS LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT OUR TOP
TWELVE NON ENGLISH LANGUAGES
SPOKEN IN LA COUNTY AS THE STATE
MENTIONED.
A REPRESENT 96% OF THIS
POPULATION HOWEVER THE REMAINING
4% OF OUR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT POPULATION REPRESENTS
OVER NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT SPEAK OVER A HUNDRED
LANGUAGES.
THE EQUIVALENT OF THE
SEVENTEENTH LARGEST CITY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
AFTER COMPTON.
WE NEED TO ALSO SERIOUSLY
EVALUATE HOW WE CAN MEET THE
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION.
AN UNDERCOUNT OF LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT POPULATIONS CAN
POTENTIALLY REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT LONG TERM FISCAL
IMPACT ON THEIR SERVICERS.
THE COUNTY ESTIMATES THAT THE
FUNDING FOR FEDERAL PROGRAMS
GUIDED BY DATED DERIVE FROM THE
CENSUS FOR THIS 4% CAP.
OF OUR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT POPULATION COULD
RESULT IN AN IMPACT AND NEARLY A
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION.
ANNUALLY OR ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
MANY OF OUR COUNTY DEPARTMENTS
HAVE EXPERIENCE ADDRESSING
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
POPULATIONS INCLUDING THE
REGISTRAR RECORDER COUNTY CLERK.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OUR COUNTY HOSPITAL
SUCH AS RENTALS DOING A TOOLS
AND STRATEGIES THAT ARE BEING
EVALUATED BY THE COUNTIES SENSES
TEEMING COMPLETE COMMITTEE.
COMPLETE CAL COMMITTEE INCLUDE
AND THIS IS WHERE YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR IDEAS.
OF UTILIZING THE REGISTRAR
RECORDERS LANGUAGE TARGETING
SYSTEM THAT IDENTIFIES LARGE
NUMBERS OF NON ENGLISH LANGUAGE
SPEAKING RESIDENTS BY VOTING
PRECINCTS.
A NUMBER OF THESE PRECINCTS ARE
IN ARE HARD TO COUNT.
AREAS AND THE REGISTRAR RECORDER
IS WORKING ON FORMATTING FAIR
DATA TO BE COMPATIBLE WITH HARD
TO COUNT CENSUS TRACKS.
SO THAT IS ONE THING WE ARE
WORKING ON ANOTHER THING -- WE
ARE LOOKING AT SOME OF WHICH WAS
MENTIONED BY DE THIS AS WELL
DEVELOPING LOOK MULTI LANGUAGE
WEBSITES CREATING TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR MULTI LINGUAL
INTERPRETERS THAT WILL VOLUNTEER
AT THE CENSUS ACTION KIOSKS.
AND ASSISTED COUNTY EVENTS.
OPENING A PUBLIC HOTLINE.
THAT UTILIZES CONTRACTED
INTERPRETER SERVICES AS NEEDED
TO ASSIST IN RESPONDING TO THE
CENSUS ENQUIRIES.
TARGET TARGETING MULTI FACETED
MEDIA WHICH YOU DISCUSSED A LOT
HERE -- AND THE OUTRAGE
OPPORTUNITIES IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES -- AND WE ALSO WILL BE
USING UTILIZING THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES BY
LEGAL RESOURCE UTILIZATION
DATABASE.
THAT CAN X. ACCESS A LIST OF
CERTIFIED BILINGUAL EMPLOYEES
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT.
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
COUNTY LOS ANGELES ADDRESSES THE
NEEDS OF COUNTY RESIDENTS IN
FORTY ONE LANGUAGES TODAY.
UTILIZING ALSO WIRELESS VIDEO
INTERPRETING SYSTEMS LIKE THE
ONE DEVELOP IT RANCHO LOS AMIGOS
HOSPITAL.
THIS SYSTEM ALLOWS PATIENTS TO
SELECT FROM FIFTY LANGUAGES AND
BE ROUTED TO AN INTERPRETER WHO
CAN ASSIST THEM IN THAT LANGUAGE.
THE NETWORK OF HEALTH WHERE
HEALTH CARE FOR INTERPRETERS
REMOTELY HAS ACCESS TO LOOK UP
TOOLS.
AND CAN HAVE FACE TO FACE
EXCHANGES TO PROVIDE KHI
SERVICES.
THIS TOOL HAS AGREED INCREASED
PATIENT ACCESS TO INTERPRETERS
BY 50%.
JUST AT RANCHO LOS AMIGOS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES WHO OPERATES RANCHO LOS
AMIGOS NOW USES THE CELLPHONE
NOW. TO PROVIDE MEDIA IMAGE
VIDEO INTERPRETER SERVICES WHICH
FURTHER INCREASES FLEXIBILITY
ACCESSIBILITY IN PROVIDING
LANGUAGE ACCESS SERVICE THE
COUNTY IS EXPLORING WHETHER THE
ACTUAL MAY BE AN OPTION.
THAT CAN BE USED FOR THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
CONCEPT OF THE COUNTIES
EXPLORING IT'S OUR INTENT TO
CONTINUE EXAMINING OPTIONS WITH
DEPARTMENTS.
AS AN OTHER SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS IN LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
THE STATE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
RECOGNIZES LA COUNTY NEEDS
SUFFICIENT TIME TO DEVELOP OF US
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN.
AND WILL INVOLVE COORDINATION
AND WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDING STAKEHOLDERS FROM
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
PHILANTHROPY AS WELL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS UNIONS
MUNICIPALITIES.
IS THIS THE CHAMBERS AND OTHERS.
TO ALLOW THE COUNTY TO PURSUE
LANGUAGE AXIS ALTERNATIVE.
STATE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS HAS
AGREED TO ALLOW THE COUNTY SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME TO PREPARE IS
LANGUAGE ACCESS STRATEGIC PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE COUNTY IN THE STATE
IN THE US CENSUS BUREAU ON THEIR
LANGUAGE ACCESS APPROACH WILL BE
CRUCIAL TO COMPLEMENT EFFORTS
AND AVOID DUPLICATION.
FLEXIBILITY AND COLLABORATION
WILL BE KEY TO THIS PROCESS
INCLUDING SHARING TRANSLATED
MATERIALS VIDEOS AND SOCIAL
MEDIA.
CONTENT FLEXIBILITY IN
RESPONDING TO LANGUAGE ACCESS
NEEDS DURING THE NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW UP.
PARTICULARLY AS REAL TIME
RESPONSE REYES AND ON THE GROUND
FEEDBACK FROM COMMUNITY AND CEOS
BECOMES.
AVAILABLE.
AND FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THE
COUNTY WORKS WITH THE STATE
MEDIA CONTRACT ON ETHNIC MEDIA
BUYS BASED ON TESTED MESSAGING
AND OTHER ELEMENTS RELATED TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS.
THIS UNDERTAKING WILL ULTIMATELY
REQUIRE THE STATE'S ONGOING
SUPPORT AND WE APPRECIATE THE
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION.
THAT STATE THE STATE ALLOCATED
TO OUR COUNTIES LOCAL COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE.
BY THE RECOGNIZING THE ENHANCE
STATE REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO AT
LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR OUR LARGE
LIMITED ENGLISH POPULATION AND
OTHER REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
ADDRESSING DIFFERENT COUNTY
POPULATIONS.
AS WELL AS AN EMPHASIS ON COUNTY
SUPPORTING US CENSUS BUREAU'S
RECRUITMENT OF A NEWMAN
ENUMERATORS WE CONTINUE TO SEE.
THE STATE SUPPORT FOR A REQUEST
OF AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION TO
HELP ENSURE A ROBUST EDUCATION
IN OUR CAMPAIGN INCLUSIVE OF ALL
OUR PARTNERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GREAT I'M MY NAME IS MANDY
PATINKIN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE TWO CAR MOVEMENT I WANT
TO THANK THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR GIVING US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE TODAY -- SINCE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HAS COME UP -- THAT'S A
VERY MUCH I HOPE IN OUR EXCHANGE
GUY GET TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MORE ABOUT THAT -- THE
JAKARTA MOVEMENT WORKS IN TWELVE
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
LARGELY THE BEEN JOB IS A
COMMUNITY ALL THE WAY FROM KERN
UP TO YOU -- CENTER COUNTIES.
THAT WE ARE PART OF THE THE
CBO'S THAT ARE SORT OF IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CBO
SPECIFICALLY IN REGION SIX WHICH
COVERS THE KERN -- TO FRESNO
COUNTY AS WELL AS REGION FOUR
WHICH COVERS MADERA UP TO SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY AND THAT WERE
PART OF THE GROUPS SPECIFICALLY
IN SACRAMENTO THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO AREA WHICH IS REGION
ONE AND REGION THREE THE BAY
AREA SO HOPEFULLY.
IT ARCHING THAT CAN PROVIDE YOU
SORT OF SOME INFORMATION WHAT'S
HAPPENING -- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- SENSE OF TWENTY TWENTY
UNDOUBTEDLY WILL BE A CHALLENGE
FOR REASONS FAR TO HUMAN -- IF
THE CITIZENSHIP QUESTION IS
INCLUDED AND AND BY ALL MEANS
THAT APPEARS TO BE THE CASE ON
TOP OF LONG STANDING STRUCTURAL
ISSUES WITH THE NOW ADDED -- IS
ANOTHER COMPONENTS OF A
RELUCTANCE THE FOR PEOPLE O
EVEN WANT TO PARTICIPATE
ESPECIALLY DUE TO MISTRUST OF
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST TO LOSE
AND IF I COULD BE A BIT
PAROCHIAL THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS
EVEN THE MOST TO LOSE -- AND AND
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN TERMS
OF THE SHEER SIZE -- IT HAVE TO
BE PAYING SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
HOW DO WE RECTIFY THE SITUATION
I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A THEME
THROUGHOUT THE DAY I SORT OF
HAVE THIS -- STRANGE -- SERENITY
PRAYER I DO WITH THE WITH THE
CENSUS WHICH IS -- YOU KNOW
PLEASE GIVE ME THE STRENGTH TO
DO WHAT I CANNOT TEAMS FEDERALLY
AND THE COURAGE TO KNOW WHAT WE
CAN DO HERE IN THE STATE AND THE
WISDOM TO KNOW THE DIFFERENCE --
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
WHAT WAS THE STANDARDS THAT WAS
FOR SHARED AND ADDS IT'S GOING --
DIRECTLY TO ACTUALLY BECOMING UP
A PLAN -- I I DO DOES SOMETHING
I JUST WANTED TO CATCH NOTICE OF
WE TALKED WE SPOKE SPECIFICALLY
OF AROUND -- THE ISSUE OF
CANTONESE MANDARIN IN CHINESE
BUT ALSO IN THAT LIST WAS
FILIPINO AND TAGALOG WHICH ARE --
SORT OF THE ESSENTIALLY THE SAME
LANGUAGE -- THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE WE HAVE TO BE WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
ETHNOGRAPHIC INCLUDING THE
LINGUISTIC EXPERTISE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE THESE
REDUNDANCIES.
WHERE DOES THE RUBBER HIT THE
ROAD I CAN TELL YOU SPECIFICALLY --
IN THE BEEN DOUBLY SPEAKING
POPULATIONS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU'RE NOT ACCOUNTED SO SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THE LANGUAGE OF
THE JOB HE HAS NEVER BEEN
REPORTED SEPARATELY.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS THE THIRD
MOST SPOKEN LANGUAGE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ALL THE WAY FROM
KERN COUNTY UP TO CENTER COUNTY
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF FRESNO
WHERE ITS FOURTH -- BECAUSE
AMONG COMMUNITY AND SACRAMENTO
BECAUSE OUR LARGE CHINESE
SPEAKING POPULATIONS.
UP A JOB HE HAS NEVER BEEN
REPORTED.
AND THAT AND THAT HAS BEEN THE
CASE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SO
EVEN WHEN WE'RE DOING THE TOP
TWELVE LANGUAGE -- AGGREGATIONS
EVEN DOT AND AND I APPRECIATE
THE STATE -- CENSUS HAS BEEN
OPEN TO THAT TO THAT DIALOGUE TO
ACTUALLY GET THEM TO USE NEW
NUMBERS TAX RELIEF MAKE THAT THE
EVEN IN THE TOP TWELVE WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THOSE LANGUAGES -- SO
YOU KNOW THESE THINGS MAY MAKE A
HUGE HUGE DIFFERENCE -- IN TERMS
OF HOW DOES THIS INFORMATION
THEN GET CYCLE AND AND TO BE
HONEST -- CENTER COUNTY TOOK A
LOT OF MY STEAM BECAUSE THE THE
EXACT QUESTIONS HERE YOU WERE
ASKING WERE VERY MUCH THE CASE.
HOW DOES THAT -- INFORMATION
FROM WHAT WAS THE STANDARDS
SECTION FROM THE PLAN HOW HOW
DOES THAT ACTUALLY FILTER I CAN
GIVE YOU SOME FEEDBACK IN TERMS
OF WHAT OF THE PRESENT
CONVERSATIONS OF A CBO SOME THE
CBO'S.
BUT WE DO HAVE A CONVERT
QUESTION ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY AS A SENATOR
LATER THAT ALSO BROUGHT UP
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARDS TO THE
STATE MEDIA CONTRACT WITH REGARD
TO PUBLIC RELATIONS.
THE R. F. P. DOES NOT HAVE AT
LEAST IN THE LANGUAGE WHEN IT
WAS INITIALLY PUBLISHED IN NOT
HAVE ENFORCEMENT MAC MECHANISMS
IN TERMS OF THAT IT HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED MECHANISMS.
WELLBUT THE STANDARDS DID.
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S BEING BRIDGE ESPECIALLY
AS WE HAVE SOME YOU KNOW AS AS
THIS INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE --
IS IS BEING FILTERED AND AND THE
PRIMARY CONTRACTORS IT TO BE --
AWARDED SO THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT -- MUCH SO IN TERMS
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WERE HAVING
WE'RE FIGURE OUT OUR CAPACITIES
THE CAPACITY IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE NEW STANDARDS AND ALL OF US
WANT TO HIT THESE GOALS.
BUT IT'S ALSO TO FIGURE OUT --
BOTH THE CBO'S AS WELL AS YOU
DON'T I MEAN TO BE FRANK.
EVEN WITHIN THE JOB IS SPEAKING
COMMUNITY WHICH IS LIKE THE ONE
OF THE TOP TEN IN THE STATE.
THE CAPACITY IS EVEN OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE ACCESS
TO GOVERNMENT AND AND ACTUALLY
ENGAGE IN THIS WORLD CAN BE
SOMETIMES VERY LIMITED SOMETIMES
COMMUNITIES FELT FORM THEIR OWN
BUBBLES.
BECAUSE THAT'S SORT OF HOW THEY
HAVE PERCEIVED STRENGTH HOW WE
GET THAT AND AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS REALLY HAVE TO BE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I MEAN WE
DON'T HAVE HAS TO DO IT IF WE DO
THAT THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL.
BUT THE BUT THE HOW IS GOING TO
BE A HUGE QUESTION THAT THAT
THAT IF WE CAN HELP SORT OUT.
AT ANOTHER -- THE ISSUE I WANTED
I WANTED FOR A REYES AND THEY'RE
IN THE REMAINING TIME WAS -- THE
THE THE RIGHT UP THE WEEK WE
WILL NEED A TRACKING SYSTEM SO
THE STATE HAS A TRACKING A
MEASUREMENT CALLED FOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING.
LIVE UPDATES TO HOW WE'RE DOING
IT BUT TO HAVE A SYSTEM LIKE PDI
BECAUSE WE WILL NEED TO TRACK
HER HOUSEHOLD SO FOR INSTANCE IF
OUR GROUP IS CANVASSING THE
SPECIFIC NEIGHBORHOOD.
YES I CAN GO TO HIGH PERCENTAGE
BUT DOBBY SPEAKING NEIGHBORHOOD
BUT IF BUT IF THERE'S A PRINT
AMONG SPEAKING PERSON I NEED TO
BE ABLE TO INDICATE THAT FOR THE
NEXT GROUP TO BE ABLE TO COME
AND SPEAK TO THEM PERFECTLY SO --
IF WE GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE P. I.
SYSTEM WHICH WOULD BE FANTASTIC
BUT TO MAKE SURE IT -- KEEPS TO
WHAT THE SENSES REQUIRES WHICH
IS NOT NAMES AND PER HOUSEHOLD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THAT'S WHAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PAN
CHAIRMAN BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
SEVEN SENATE AND ASSEMBLY FLIGHT
COMMITTEES ON THE CENSUS
LEGISLATIVE STAFF IN HONOR GAS
AND JESSICA WITH THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT.
RELATIONS AT THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND I AM JOINED TODAY
ALSO BY MY COLLEAGUE SOLVE YOUR
MONTEZ HE WAS OUR CENTERS TWENTY
TWENTY PROJECT MANAGER.
OUR TEAM IS LUCKY WELL
REPRESENTED ON BOTH CENTERS THAT
COMMITTEES WITH THE LEADERSHIP
OF SENATOR AMBER EXTENDER CHIANG
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN.
AND WE'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON ENSURING
THAT EVERYONE IS ACCOUNTED FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENTS AYS AND
FOR ALL THE RESOURCES THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO BE A PARTNER THROUGHOUT THE
NEXT YEAR.
IT ALSO LIKE TO THINK THIRTY AT
FOR THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
YOU'VE BEEN ASSET MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE COUNTY AS WE BEGAN OUR
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE.
AND WE LOOK FOR TO FURTHER
COLLABORATION WITH THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANDERSON OR OTHER REGIONAL
PARTNERS PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO MEDIA OUT REGION
ENGAGE THEM.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
UPDATE AS TO WHERE WE ARE IN OUR
CURRENT EFFORTS WITH REGARDS TO
THE AND SAYS IN.
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR
BOARD CREATED AID AD HOC
COMMITTEE.
ON THE CENSUS THE COMMITTEE IS
COMPRISED OF FIRST DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR INJURE DEL AND FOR
FOURTH DISTRICT SUPERVISOR DODGY
FEE.
ACCORDING TO SOARED THE SENSUAL
IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICTS
HAVE CITIES WHICH CONTAINED THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT HARD TO HAVE
COUNT COMMUNITIES WITHIN OUR
COUNTY.
AND IN A IN OCTOBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY CENTER AT
THE AN AUTHORIZATION
PARTICIPATION WITH THE STATE.
AND THEN IN FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR THEY AGREED ON A COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL
AS ITS STRUCTURE AND WE HAVE.
AND FIVE KEY SUBCOMMITTEES
WITHIN OUR COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE INCLUDING THE ONE MOST
TOPICAL FULL GOOD TODAY THE
IMMIGRANT LIMITED ENGLISH AND
LANGUAGE ACCESS COMMITTEE.
WITH THE LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT
ON OUR BOARD WE BEGAN TO WORK ON
CREATING A KICK OFF EVENT WHICH
IS ULTIMATELY HELD ON APRIL
SIXTEENTH.
SUPERVISORS DOWN CHIEF YOU LET
THE MEETING.
AND WE WERE FORTUNATE
REPRESENTATIVES FOR
CONGRESSIONAL STATE DELEGATIONS
AND IT ATTENDANCE ALONG WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE REST U.
S. CENSUS BUREAU IN CALIFORNIA
CENTERS.
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE HAD OVER
EIGHTY STAKEHOLDER HOLDER GROUPS
REPRESENTED.
AS I MENTIONED OUR IMMIGRANT
LIMITED ENGLISH IN LANGUAGE
ACCESS COMMITTEE AND AT THAT.
AT THAT KICK OFF ME WE DISCUSSED
WAYS TO BETTER ENGAGEOUR
CONSTITUENTS IS LANGUAGE ACCESS
ISSUES.
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE ALONG WITH THE
OTHER FOUR HAS BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS THEIR RESPECTIVE AREAS
AND PROVIDE INSIGHT ON HOW TO
BEST ADDRESS ISSUES THAT MAY
AFFECT LANGUAGE ACCESSIBILITY.
MAY STAFF AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR CBO PARTNERS ON
LANGUAGE ACCESS RELATED ISSUES
AND LOOK FORWARD TO DOING SO
WITHIN THE ACT NEXT YEAR.
WE HAD REVIEWED THE MARCH SIX
TWENTY NINETEEN LANGUAGE AND
COMMUNICATION ACCESS TANDARDS
DOCUMENT PUBLISHED BY THE
STATE'S.
I'M CENTERS TWENTY TWENTY OFFICE
AND ACCORDING TO THAT REPORT
ORANGE COUNTY'S TOP SIX NON
ENGLISH LANGUAGES.
INCLUDED SPANISH VIETNAMESE
KOREAN CHINESE WHICH INCLUDED
MANDARIN CANTONESE WE DISCUSSED
THE GARLIC AND PERSIAN WHICH
INCLUDES FORESEEN DARI.
OUR NEXT THREE LANGUAGES ARE
ARABIC JAPANESE IN COMMAND THE
OFFICIAL LANGUAGE OF CAMBODIA.
AS A RESULT AS WE WORK TO DRAFT
OUR STRATEGIC PLAN WILL BE
FOCUSED ON IDENTIFYING
STRATEGIES TO BEST REACH ALL
THESE COMMUNITIES RETRACTED
MESSENGERS KEY COMMUNITY EVENTS.
AND OTHER STRATEGIES WITH CBO
PARTNERS WHO WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THESE HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE CAMBODIAN FAMILY CBO IS A
MEMBER OF OUR COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE AND IS BELIEVE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE EXPERIENCE A
SIGNIFICANT UNDER COUNT IN.
TWENTY TEN WE NEED TO GO OVER
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE INSTEAD OF
EXPECTING THEM TO COME TO PASS.
OUR INDIVIDUAL OUR INITIAL
COMPLETE COUNT SUBCOMMITTEE
BRAINSTORMING SESSION AND
SUBSEQUENT SURVEY HAS ALREADY
GENERATED LOTS OF CREDIT I TIAS
SUCH AS CROSS PROMOTING.
AS PART OF THE CAMINO DE AMISTAD
WERE INDIVIDUALS GO DOOR TO DOOR
TO REMIND FAMILIES ABOUT HIGH
SCHOOL REGISTRATION AND FIRST
DAY OF HIGH SCHOOL IN SANTA ANA.
AND THIS IS ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOINED
SORRY WITH MATCHING.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE HIRING OF
THE STATE OUT REGION PUBLIC
RELATIONS CAMPAIGN CONTRACTOR
AND WE'VE BEEN WAITING TO HIRE A
PUBLIC RELATIONS FIRM TO
COMPLEMENT THE STATE WIDE
EFFORTS.
WELL LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MY CAR TARGETED MESSAGING OF
TIRED OF CONCENTRATED GROUPS
INCLUDING THE USE OF OUR MANY
LOCAL ETHNIC MEDIA OUTLETS.
WE APPRECIATE AND WE'RE EXCITED
TO HEAR THE STATE'S PLANS TO
MAKE MATERIALS AVAILABLE
MULTIPLE LANGUAGE TO USE BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THIS ONE
SHOULD HELP ENSURE CONSISTENCY A
MESSAGE.
AND A COMEY AND ECONOMIES OF
SCALE WHILE ALLOWING US TO USE
OUR RESOURCE TO GET THE MOST
MATERIALS OUT TO THOSE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO INCLUDING
INFORMATION FROM THE MAY
SEVENTEENTH WERE WITH REPORT
SEVENTEENTH REPORT.
INTO OUR STRATEGIC PLAN ALTHOUGH
ON THAT DEADLINE OF A MARK ME
THIRTY AT THE DEADLINE GIVEN US
ONLY ABOUT THIRTEEN DAYS TO
INCORPORATE THAT I THINK WILL BE
VERY CHALLENGING SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
STATE ON ANY.
POSSIBLE AND EXTENSIONS THERE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT REPRESENT ANY WITH THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIC PLAN
THAT WE CAN.
THE ONE I THINK THE JOINT
COMMITTEE AGAIN FOR INVITING US
TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU ALL OVER THE NEXT
YEAR THANK YOU.
OKAY THANKS FOR MUCH QUESTIONS
WERE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLED
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL OF A
PARTICULAR YOU MISS WITH FOR
COMING TO SACRAMENTO. FOR THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT EFFORT --
AND ALSO IS YOU KNOW BUT OTHERS
MAY NOT THAT ORANGE CUNTY IS
NOT THE SAME PLACE AS IT USED TO
BE THAT THE DIVERSITY THE
EXISTING ORANGE COUNTY IS NOW
QUITE PROFOUND -- THAT WE HAVE
VERY LARGE API COMMUNITIES VERY
LARGE LATINO CAM IN AND AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT.
WE'RE CONCERNED MAY BE UNDER
COUNTED I KNOW YOU'RE DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF MAKING SURE
THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN SO ONE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING TODAY.
QUESTIONS.
SO -- I SHE FIRST QUESTION FOR
THIS WITNESS THE ORANGE COUNTY --
SO WHAT I HEARD FROM -- THIS
PARK IT LA IS LIKE WE NEED FIVE
MILLION MORE DOLLARS BECAUSE OF
LANGUAGE.
THE DAY ARE YOU FEELING THE SAME
WAY I NEED MORE MONEY FOR
LANGUAGE OR DOES IT PRETTY CLEAR
THAT YOU THE MONEY YOU GOT YOU
GOT PRETTY CLEAR DIRECTION ABOUT
HOW.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THE THE
UPDATED REPORT.
I THINK AFTER THE ANALYZING THAT
WILL HAVE A BETTER IDEA.
AS TO AS TO THE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS
OKAY SO.
THE RIGHT NOW.
NOT SURPRISINGLY DON'T KNOW YET
BECAUSE WE ARE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
STANDARDS ARE OKAY.
AND AND I APPRECIATE YOU DID
MAKE NOTE I WAS ALSO THINKING
SOMEWHAT THE SAME THING OKAY MAY
SEVENTEENTH TO GET DOCUMENTS MAY
THIRTIETH YOU GOT TO RESPOND.
SO I MEAN.
YOU HAVE FIVE SOME IDEA WHAT
MIGHT BE IN THERE BUT ON WHAT IT
ACTUALLY IS INTO YOU GET IT
RIGHT.
CENTER FOR ASKED WE ALSO THAT
DOCUMENTS APPROVED BY OUR BOARD
SO WE WILL NEED TIME FOR BOARD
TO APPROVE -- BOTH OUR AD HOC IN
OUR BOARD TO APPROVE -- OKAY
STRATEGIC PLAN AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US FOR OUR ELECTED
BOARD TO WEIGH IN AND REALLY AND
I'D.
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN WOULD THAT BE THE SAME IN
LA AS WELL.
THE WITH THE STATE LAST MONTH
THAT -- WE WERE LOOKING -- TO
MAYBE DO SOMETHING MORE
COMPREHENSIVE BY THE NEXT
QUARTERLY REPORT ON JULY FIRST --
BECAUSE THAT WOULD GIVE US A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO GO
THROUGH THESE PROCESS SEES AND
BAD.
A LANGUAGE ACCESS HEY AND SO --
I GUESS -- DIRECTOR CRAFTING
COMMON WHEN SHE DOES A
REFLECTION ON DOES THAT CHANGE
THE TIMELINE FOR ALL THE OTHER
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT -- SO.
SHE'S SHAKING HER HEAD SO I
THINK THAT'S A PRELIMINARY
ANSWER -- SO LET ME ASK YOU THIS
PART.
YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT WE NEED
FIVE MILLION MORE -- I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT WE'VE THIS IS A
HISTORIC LEVEL OF INVESTMENT IN
THE CENSUS I MEAN WHAT I DON'T
THINK THE CITY CALIFORNIA THE
STATE GOVERNMENT'S EVER PUT IN --
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE HAVE WE'RE
PLANNING TO BUT WE VERY BALLOT
HERE HUNDRED MILLION WERE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING ANOTHER
FIFTY FOUR MILLION THAT'S A LOT
OF MONEY.
AND THEN YOU'RE COMING BACK AND
SAYING I NEED FIVE MILLION MORE
SO WHAT DO YOU GUYS SPEND THE
FIVE MILLION MORE ON THAT.
AND THEN WE WHAT WE REALLOCATED
WHAT NINE MILLION TO LA COUNTY
SO.
I REALIZE IT'S A VERY BIG COUNTY --
BUT I WILL POINT OUT THAT TAXES
I THINK IS ALLOCATED ZERO NEW
YORK IS ALLOCATED TO MILLION.
SO I MEAN THOSE ARE BIG STATES
AND I REALIZE THAT WE SINCE
WE'RE COMPARING LA TO STATES SO
WE'RE GIVING YOU NINE MILLION.
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH -- YOU
REQUESTED TWELVE MILLION LAST
OKAY WHICH YOU GAVE US NINE FOUR
WHICH IS CRACK SO THERE'S THE
TWO POINT SIX MILLION DOLLAR GAP
THERE.
AND THAT CAP DID DRESS LANGUAGE
ACCESS SPECIFICALLY -- IN
ADDITION THOUGH THIS STATE IS
ADDED SOME NEW REQUIREMENTS ONE
BEING THEY'RE ASKING US TO HELP
THE US CENSUS BUREAU WITH
RECRUITMENT FOR ENUMERATORS WE
HAD TO ASSUME THAT THAT WAS THE
U. S. CENSUS BUREAU'S ROLE.
AND WE WERE NOT ANTICIPATING
BECOMING A JOB RECRUITMENT --
EFFORT FOR THE US CENSUS BUREAU
WE HAVE BEGUN LOOKING AT HOW WE
ARE GOING TO DO THAT WE HAVE
PULLED TOGETHER OUR DEPARTMENTS
THAT DO YOU -- SINCE SUCH AS OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OUR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES PEOPLE THAT WERE
WAITING CLIENTS.
AND FOLKS IN OUR COUNTY WOULD
POTENTIALLY BE ENUMERATORS BUT
IN ORDER TO DO -- A ROBUST
EFFORT AROUND ENUMERATOR
RECRUITMENT THAT WILL REQUIRE
RESOURCES SO JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA IN.
TWENTY TEN THERE WERE ELEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
ENUMERATORS FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
AND THAT WAS IN THE YEAR WHERE
THERE WAS A LOT MORE
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHERE RECRUITMENT WAS A LOT
EASIER -- THEN WHAT WILL FACE
GOING FORWARD IN THIS EFFORT.
SO THAT'S ONE BIG AREA THAT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOBILIZE AROUND.
THERE WAS ALSO SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WHICH IS LA COUNTY HAS.
AMONGST THE LARGEST OF THE
LARGEST ALSO WHO ONE OF THE
LARGEST NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES LA CITY.
ALONE IS THE SECOND LARGEST IN
THE NATION -- LA COUNTY BEING
THE LARGEST COUNTY OF NATIVE
AMERICANS -- SO AGAIN -- THERE'S
INTEREST FROM OUR LOS ANGELES
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMISSION TO DO
A REQUEST EFFORT AROUND THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
SO THESE -- SOME OF THOSE --
OTHER AREAS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT INCLUDE -- ACCESS FOR
DISABILITY SO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WAS NOT ADDRESSED
ORIGINALLY -- LAST YEAR AND THAT
IS NOW AN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS -- THAT'S BEING
ASKED OF COUNTIES TO CONSIDER
AND INCLUDE IT'S NOT REALLY AN
OPTION IS TO BE INCLUDED -- AND
THEN ALSO -- BASICALLY
IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS WORKING WITH OUR KENNY
WHITE CENSUS ACTION KIOSKS AND
GOODWILL AMBASSADORS TO TO MOVE
THIS EFFORT OUT UTILIZING
WHATEVER TOOLS WHETHER IT'S
UNIONS A HIGHER EDUCATION
WHATEVER METHOD WE CAN USE --
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO -- SOME
APPS THAT WE ARE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THAT WE'VE BEEN --
ASKING THE STATE TO LOOK AT
NEGOTIATING A STATEWIDE PLAN AND
THEN.
BASICALLY -- SPREADING THAT COST
TO COUNTIES ON A PRO RATED BASIS
WITH LA COUNTY PICKING UP MAYBE
A LARGER SHARE BECAUSE WE ARE A
LARGER COUNTY THEN.
MAYBE A SMALLER COUNTY WHICH
SHOULD JUST GET THE APP FOR FREE.
I'M SO THINGS LKE THAT HAVE ALL
BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT YES SENATOR ASA.
MY QUESTION IS.
I DO THINK. FOR MONEY SHOULD GO.
TO YOU BECAUSE THIS IS OUR
CHANCE FOR TEN YEARS -- WE CAN
COME BACK LATER AND SAY WE
SHOULD OF GOOD OF OF BUT THERE
IS THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
ALREADY EXIST.
AS FAR AS YOU VIEW BEACH.
TALKED ABOUT THAT -- COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS A NUMBER OF
OF WAYS MY QUESTION IS -- WHAT
ABOUT THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM?
AS FAR AS BEING A TRUSTED --
PARTNER -- I RAISE THAT --
SEVERAL TIMES IN DIFFERENT
MEETINGS AND IT JUST SEEMS TO ME.
THEY ARE ALREADY IN PLACE TALK
ABOUT HAVING ACCESS.
TO EVERY SINGLE.
WHETHER IT'S TINY COMMUNITY
LARGER DOESN'T MATTER.
ALL OUR KIDS GO TO SCHOOL GO TO
A SCHOOL.
OF IT SEEMS TO ME IS A SO HOW
WOULD YOU.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE DURABLE
PARTNER AND HOW WOULD YOU GO
ABOUT GETTING THE MOST.
OUT OF THE THE EDUCATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM.
TEENY WEENY KIDS TO WRITE SO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THERE AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- LAUSD HAS PREPARED
A PLAN FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND INCLUDES
ALSO ADULT EDUCATION.
AND THEY'RE ALREADY -- STARTING
TO USE THE LOGO FOR THIS THAT
THE STATE UTILIZES ON THEIR
DOCUMENTS -- AND THEY HAVE THE
WE ARE.
ONE PROGRAM FOR THEIR DREAMERS
AND THAT'S HOW THEY'RE PUSHING
OUT THE PROGRAM.
THAT PLAN WAS SHARED WITH LEGO.
LAKE TAHOE IS UTILIZING OPTIONS
FOR THE OTHER.
SEVENTY NINE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
CONSIDER -- SOME OF THE OPTIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY ARTICULATED IN
THE PLAN AND ARE AVAILABLE WE
ALSO SENT THE PLAN TO THE STATE
SO THAT THEY ARE ALSO AWARE OF
WHAT -- THE LAUSD SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS PLANNING TO DO AND
PUSH OUT.
IF I COULD -- REPRESENT A VERY
DIFFERENT CASE STUDY SO I I'M
ACTUALLY ON THE SCHOOL BOARD --
ESSENTIAL UNIFIED WHICH IS IN
THE CITY OF FRESNO.
AND TO BE FRANK PRESENT UNIFIED
WHICH IS THE FOURTH LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE.
THREE TO FIVE CLOVIS UNIFIED TO
MY KNOWLEDGE NONE OF THEM HAVE
ACTUALLY REALLY ACTIVELY ENGAGED
I I ABSOLUTELY AGREE IT'S IT'S A
IT'S A HUGE POTENTIAL -- POINT --
TO MY KNOWLEDGE AND THIS COULD
BE -- CORRECTED IS ONLY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WAS CURRENTLY
SET ASIDE FOR SCHOOLS
SPECIFICALLY IN THE IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET.
BUT THOUGHT ABOUT MAYBE A PLACE
AND HOW MUCH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE EVEN AWARE OF THOUGHTS AND
HOW MANY PIECES CAN BE CUT TO
MILLION INTO.
AS AS UP.
FOR A DIFFERENT SORT OF
CONVERSATION.
IN AND WE'VE INVOLVED THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY WITHIN OUR
COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEE AND ARE
REALLY LOOKING TO THEM TO HELP
GIVE US SOME OF THOSE IDEAS AND
AS TO HOW BEST TO REACH OUT.
TO THE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
AND YOUNG ADULTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS -- I'D STOW SO
WHAT ELEMENT NODE THAT
ESTABLISHES WHAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT.
THE WE WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT CDOS
AND USING CVS STORE SAID MANAGED
MESSENGERS ARE LEADERS A CBO'S
AND SO FORTH BUT THE CAPACITY.
THAT AND THE THE NEED TO PERHAPS
INVEST IN SOME CAPACITY BUILDING.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'LL FIND
OURSELVES ON APRIL FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THEY'RE GONNA
BE LIKE WELL WE'RE KIND OF BUSY
DOING A LOT OF THINGS RIGHT
ASIDE FROM THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY WHICH WOULD HAPPEN THE
MONTH BEFORE BUT I MEAN JUST IN
THE NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS
AND HOW TO REBUILD THEIR
CAPACITY. TO ACCOMMODATE MORE
THAT CLOSELY SURE IT MEANS
SPECIFICALLY DIFFERENT --
DIFFERENT OF OUR ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES HERE JUST IN TERMS
OF THEIR OWN HISTORIES HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF OF OF
ENGAGEMENT SO FOR OUR EAST ASIAN
COMMUNITIES ARE YOU HAVE
PROBABLY THE MOST ROBUST SYSTEMS
BEEN A BEEN BUILT OUT THAT TOOK
A CENTURY AGO CENTER TO HAVE TO
WOULD THAT BE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHINESE KOREAN
AND JAPANESE COMMUNITIES -- FOR
OUR SOUTHEAST ASIAN COMMUNITIES
SPECIFICALLY FOR AMONG
COMMUNITIES IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT IMMIGRANT HISTORY IN
TERMS OF THE UNITED STATES ON
THE FEDERAL AGO FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SIDE RESETTLING
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN THE
FRESNO AND SACRAMENTO AREAS.
BUT HAVING DONE SO.
HELPING TO BUILD SOME OF THE
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS SO WHAT
BECOMES THE CAPACITY THIS
COMMITTEES DIFFERENT NOW IN
TERMS OF THE CAMBODIAN
POPULATION.
DOES NOT HAVE THE SAME LEVELS OF
SERVICE SERVICES THE YEMENIS
POPULATION DOES NOT HAPPEN THE
SAME SERVICE.
IN THE PUNJABI SPEAKING
COMMUNITY YOU HAVE ABOUT NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
WE'RE PROBABLY THE ONLY CBO THAT
DOESN'T DO LIKE CULTURAL DANCING
RESPOND AS OFFICIAL RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTION.
SO YOUR CAPACITIES TO REALLY
ENGAGE ARE STILL RELATIVELY
LIMITED.
THE CENSUS ISN'T GOING TO BE A
STAR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD UP
BUT IT IS SOMETHING FOR FOR US
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES SENATOR
RAZA YES.
SURE YES WITH.
THE IN THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU
GIVING SO WHAT DO YOU SUGGEST
[inaudible]
WE DO.
ULTIMATELY THE CONTRACT.
THANK YOU HAVE A REALLY GOOD
POINT IS WE'RE WE'RE REACHING
OUT TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LET'S SAY WE DO.
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE.
AND THE CAPACITY ISN'T THERE IN
CERTAIN HARD TO COUNT OUR TO
ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES.
WHAT CAN WE THINK ABOUT DOING A
YEAR BEFORE?
SO.
IF I CAN GIVE YOU EXAMPLE IN
REGION SIX WHICH IS OUR OUR KERN
COUNTY TO TO FRESNO COUNTY
COMMUNITY -- COMMUNION ALSO
GIVEN EXAMPLE IN OUR REGION.
FOR IT REGION SIXTY AWARD WAS
GIVEN TO THE ZERO THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HEALTH A FUND
WHICH IS PART OF THIS YEAR
HEALTH FOUNDATION NUMBER OF
OTHERS ARE PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS.
WHAT I CAN SAY IS AT LEAST IN
THAT AREA BECAUSE THEY FIND A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT GROUPS THEY
THEY HAVE?
PROBABLY A SENSE BETTER THAN
MOST OF WHAT ARE THE CAPACITY OF
THE DIFFERENT GROUPS AND WHAT
ARE THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
GROUPS ON THE GROUND.
I CAN SAY THEY'RE MAKING A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT IN A IN ALL LAKE
MEANS I I BELIEVE THEY ARE AND
AND TO BE HONEST EVEN ON THE
STATE -- SIDE -- THEY HAVE A
VERY POWERFUL TEAM I MEAN I'VE
GOT TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH SOME
OF THE MEMBERS SO THE GAPS ARE
KNOWN TO EXIST.
NOW YOU'RE THE HARDER PART OF
YOUR QUESTION IS HOW DO WE FEEL
THOSE OUT.
I I THINK IT'S JUST CONTINUE
USING LIKE TRYING TO EXTEND OUR
NETWORKS LARGER CASTLE LARGER
NOT MAYBE THAT LOOKS LIKE A TOWN
HALL IN IN IN A SPECIFIC AREA
BECAUSE HOW DO WE DO KNOW THAT
THAT GAPS EXIST AND ESPECIALLY
IF THE PLAN IS GOING TO CALL FOR
THAT.
NEW FORMULA THAT WAS PRESENTED
TO US THAT ABOVE -- FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND AS THE MEAN -- THE
MEDIAN POPULATION THAT THAT
WOULD BE AND THERE'S THREE
THOUSAND LANGUAGE SPEAKERS AT
THAT SHOULD THE TRIGGER.
IT YEAH I'M JUST GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
EQUATION BECAUSE LIMIT LET ME
GIVE AN EXAMPLE SO -- IN FRESNO
COUNTY TO GO TO GARLIC WOULD NOT
BE A PROBABLY IN OUR IN OUR POOL
ON THE BOTTOM OF OUR TOP SIX
POSSIBLY BUT NOT BUT IT WOULD
TRIGGER THAT THREE THOUSAND
MEASURE -- CURRENTLY AT THE
TABLE DO WE HAVE A GROUP THAT
FOCUSES ON FILIPINO AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES NOW WE DON'T.
AND SO WE HAVE GROUPS THAT --
GENERICALLY DO SORT OF A LARGER
ASIAN AMERICAN POPULATIONS --
THE A AND AND AND EVEN WITHIN
YOU KNOW BECAUSE ASIAN AMERICAN
IS A IS A CONSTRUCT YOU KNOW IT
IT'S IT'S A POLITICAL STRUCK
CONTRACT THAT HAS A LOT OF POWER
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WHEN IT
ACTUALLY COMES DOWN TO SERVICES
PROVIDED.
YOU'LL GO TO WHO YOU KNOW AND
AND AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW OTHER
COMMUNITIES THINGS DON'T DON'T --
MESH OUT GOING AGAINST PACIFIC
WE IN FRESNO -- THE NUMBER OF
OUR COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY FROM
THE STATE OF OAXACA IN IN IN
MEXICO ESPECIALLY SORT OF
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES -- SO THE
AREA WERE I'M SCHOOL BOARD
TRUSTEE AHA HUGE NUMBER OF
MYSTICAL SPEAKERS AS A POLITICAL
SPEAKERS.
ARE THOSE CURRENTLY WE KNOW WE
HAVE A GAP WE HAD NO ONE GROUP
IN MADERA THAT THAT YOU KNOW HOW
SOME [inaudible]
IT WORKS.
WE KNOW THE GAPS EXIST THE STATE
ABSOLUTELY KNOWS THE GAPS EXIST
AND THEY'RE PUSHING ON US.
TOO BUT BUT IN A IN A IN A
POSITIVE WAY WE'RE WE'RE PUSHING
CHALLENGING EACH OTHER -- BUT
ARE THESE ROBUST EVEN IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES HIMSELF SOMETIMES
AND SOMETIMES NOT [inaudible]
YEAH.
HEY RIGHT WELL THANK IS ALSO
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND REALLY APPRECIATE -- THE
INSIGHTS THAT YOU BROUGHT.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
RIGHT TWELVE BRING UP THE RECTOR
YOU MAYBE YOU CAN.
GIVE US YOUR THOUGHTS AND
REFLECTIONS ON WHAT YOU HEARD
FROM OUR PREVIOUS TWO PANELS
APPRECIATE YOU AGAIN STAYING FOR
THE FOR FOR FOR BOTH OF THEM THE
AND LISTENING TO TO THAT THAT
SECTION.
NO ABSOLUTELY THAT WAS -- VERY
HELPFUL IN TERMS OF LISTEN TO
THAT I WANT TO JUST CLARIFY ONE
THING WHICH IS -- IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE STRATEGIC
PLANS THAT ARE DUE FOR OUR
COUNTIES -- BY FORGETTING TO USE
THE WORD OF THE NO ONE POINT
FOUR ONE POINT SIX WERE DUE IN
THEIR THING AND WE'RE NOT ASKING
LAW RASKIN THEM.
WHERE WE ARE QUESTIONS QUESTION
YOUR ASSISTANCE CENTERS BE?
AND OF COURSE THEY KNOW THEIR
MAP AND AND YOU CAN OVERLAY WE
HAVE THEY HAVE IT ON THE HARD TO
COME OUT THOSE LANGUAGES.
SO WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR THAT
FURTHER PLAN -- BUT WE'D LIKE
THAT FOR THE PLAN THAT DOROTHEA.
REGARDED IN JULY SO IT'S IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO FOR MAY THIRTIETH -- AND EACH
OF OUR RPM'S CAN WORK WITH THAT
SO THIS RECORD BY THAT --
SECONDLY I REALLY APPRECIATE
HEARING -- MIGHT REACH TEAM
LEADERSHIP IS HERE AND I'M SO
GLAD THEY COULD HEAR THIS FIRST
HAND -- I HEAR THAT THEY WANT
CLEAR DIRECTION.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT SO THAT
REALLY IS UPON MY TEAM
UNDERSTANDING AMONGST ALL OF
OURS IN EACH RPM IS TO HAVE THE
SAME UNDERSTANDING -- AND TO
CLEARLY BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE --
WE ALSO HEARD FROM ADDITIONAL
COUNTIES -- LAST WEEK AND WE'RE
SETTING UP ADDITIONAL
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS TO GET THE
CALLS BECAUSE HE'S ACTION LONGER
DOING THOSE CALLS WILL BE ONE
INCREASE THAT.
NOW IN TERMS OF THE SORT OF
MULTI PRONG IN LEAVING PEOPLE
OUT WE ALSO AWARDED NEARLY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO HANDLE THE
STATE WIDE WHICH INCLUDES ME
COPE WHICH DOES THE INTO HIS
LANGUAGE HIS.
WHICH INCLUDES -- AJ A WHICH
LOOKS AT THAT SO NOT WE'RE NOT
JUST PRESSING SO HARD ON THE
REGIONAL AND THE COUNTIES WERE
MAKING SURE THAT WE WANT TO DO
SOME OF THAT COVERAGE IN TERMS
OF GAPS -- TO SENT TOSCHES
COMMENTS ABOUT THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WE DO HAVE THAT IN PLACE --
WOMEN AND THINK IT'S YOU'RE
SAYING IT'S A BIG STATE THESE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WORKSHOPS OR
IN THE COMMUNITY IS AND BEING
REGIONAL ALLIES AND WE WANT TO
GET THAT RESPONSE BACK BUT IT.
DOES TAKE AWHILE TO GET TO ALL
OF THEM -- IN TERMS OF SENATOR
UMBERG'S THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW DO
YOU MEASURE THIS AND HOW DO
AUTUMN ACCOUNTABLE I MEAN THE
ONE THING WE DO HAVE.
IS THE HOLDER FUNDING AND NOBODY
WANTS TO HOLD THAT BACK BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE GETTING THE WORK DONE SO
I APPRECIATE WHAT NON DEEP SAID
IN TERMS OF WE WANT TO WORK
GATHER WHO WANT TO CHALLENGE
OURSELVES -- AND I JUST WANNA --
THANK YOU AGAIN -- FOR THE TIME
TO HEAR EVERYTHING FROM PEOPLE.
OKAY THANK YOU -- IF YOU KNOW
AND AND ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- SIR A BURKE.
WE WANT TO HELP YOU TO DO AN
OUTSTANDING JOB -- I WANNA
PUTTING ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ON
YOU I KNOW YOU'RE FEELING IT
ALREADY.
BUT THIS IS IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM YOU'RE
ALL LEADERS IN THIS ROOM.
AND WE'RE ALL ACCOUNTABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET A DECENT
COUNT.
THANK YOU.
A YES CENTER BERMAN YEAH AND AND
JUST -- THAT IN A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT A JUMP IN AND OUT
ALL DAY AND THAT WASN'T FOR LACK
OF QUESTIONS TO ASK BUT I KNOW
THAT MY COLLEAGUES TO THE GREAT
JOB OF COVERING ALL THE GROUND
BUT IT DID I I THINK WAS VERY
IT'S VERY HELPFUL TO GET.
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM TOGETHER
FROM THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS -- BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
A LOT OF FEEDBACK SOME FOLKS ARE
VERY HAPPY SOME FOLKS ARE VERY
FRUSTRATED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATE BY NO MEANS IS A
BOTTLE NECK STOPPING ANY OF OUR
COUNTIES -- IN THE CBO IS FROM
FROM GETTING WORK DONE AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE --
YOU KNOW REALLY PROVIDING THEM
WITH ALL THE THAT THE TOOLS IN A
TIMELY MANNER -- AND TRYING TO
MAKE THINGS AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE AND AND MINIMIZE THE
CONFUSION SO -- THE ONLY WAY WE
DO THAT IS BY KNOWING WHEN AND
WHERE THEY'RE CONFUSED AND AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES AND UNITED STATES
LUCKILY WE'RE GETTING STARTED
EARLY AND AND THERE IS -- YEAH
TIME TO GET THAT FEEDBACK AND
AND KIND OF ITERATE AS WE GO --
WHICH I THINK TODAY WAS IT WAS A
BIG ROLE IN TERMS OF GETTING
THAT NECESSARY FEEDBACK.
THANKS.
HEY NEAR THERE.
SO.
I DID A REGIS SAYS THAT -- I SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR STAYING FOR THE WHOLE
HEARING APPRECIATE YOUR INITIAL
PRESENTATION.
I THINK IS A I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT YOUR LEADERSHIP TEAM YOU
I THINK -- YOU HEARD THE
QUESTIONS YOU'VE HEARD -- THE
COMMENTS FROM THE VARIOUS
PANELISTS.
HOW WE HAVE ELEVEN MONTHS AND I
KNOW YOU THAT AND YOU KNOW THAT
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE SO AND --
WE HAVE A TIME LINE WE HAVE TO
GET THROUGH BUT ALSO TO BE SURE
THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL AND I THINK
IT'S CENTER ON BURKE SAID IS IS
THAT -- NO ALL IN THIS TOGETHER
RIGHT AND WE'D WANT TO BE SURE
WE GET EVERYONE -- COUNTED --
THE MATTER.
AND WE'LL GET TO DO ALL THE
RIGHT A DIFFERENT THINGS SOME OF
WHICH WE CAN'T CONTROL.
AS A POINTED OUT YOU KNOW WE AND
BUT OTHERS WE CAN AND WE'RE
MAKING I THINK IN A PRESS
INVESTMENT IN MAKING THE
SUCCESSFUL WILL BE SURE THAT --
THAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
SEE THAT THE INVESTMENT PAYS OFF
AS WELL SO I KNOW YOU'RE YOU AND
YOUR TEAM AT THE POINT A SPEAR
MAKING THAT HAPPEN AND SO HE WE
AND OUR OVERSIGHT ROLE NEED TO
ALSO -- SURE THAT SO I THINK --
SOME GREATER CLARITY I THINK
SOUNDS LIKE IS WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE -- SOME
PERHAPS MORE DIRECTION NAY PRE
SHEET THAT YOU PRIDE OF THE
GRASSROOTS APPROACH A PRIDE
GIVING PEOPLE A LITTLE MORE BUT
I THINK AT SOME POINT.
WE NEED SOME MORE FOCUS BEFORE
THE TO KNOW WHAT'S EXPECTED TO
DO SO THEY CAN KNOW WHAT TO
EXECUTE.
AND I THINK THAT -- THAT'S THESE
SOMETHING THAT I'M HEARING A
LITTLE BIT AND SO WE LOOK -- FOR
TO FURTHER UPDATES IS THIS IS
MISS FORD SO THANKS VERY MUCH
AND LOOK FOR TO OUR CONTINUING A
CONVERSATION SO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SALES OF THE VIDEO GO AHEAD TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT THEN SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DIRECT BECAUSE OF SELF
THERE'S PUBLIC COMMENT TO PEOPLE
CAN.
COME TO THE BACK MICROPHONE AND
I GUESS -- TECHNICALLY SHOULD
ALSO SIGN IN SO WE KNOW WHO YOU
ARE -- AND I'VE ASK IF YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR COMMENT TO A MINUTE --
CERTAINLY FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
ANY SORT OF FURTHER WRITTEN
COMMENTS -- TO OUR COMMITTEE AS
WELL IF YOU WISH -- TO IF YOU
CAN THE COVERED ALL YOUR REMARKS
THAT THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
HELLO THANK YOU AGAIN HI MY NAME
IS KELLY AND I'M WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER ALSO KNOWN AS C. RAG --
WE'VE FOCUS ON NATIONAL AND
STATE WHY ADVOCACY FOR SOUTHEAST
ASIAN COMMUNITIES -- AND IT ONE
OF THINGS I'VE MENTIONED THE
PASSES AYE -- THE SENSES IS
ACTUALLY A REALLY IMPORTANT BODY
OF DATA FOR AS BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY.
ONLY THE THE ONLY NATIONAL BODY
AT THE THAT THAT THIS AGGREGATE
SOME OF OUR SOUTHEAST ASIAN
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE'RE REALLY
GLAD TO SEE THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING AND
INVESTING IN ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S SENSES COMPLETE
COUNT -- IS HAPPENING ESPECIALLY
WITH THE LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN --
AND ALSO THAT CALIFORNIA IS
INVESTING FUNDING AND TO HARD TO
REACH COMMUNITIES -- I'D LIKE TO
JUST LIFT OF THE SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE ALREADY MADE
TODAY ONE IS ENSURING THAT THE
SECOND ITERATION.
OF THE PLAN IS OPERATIONAL WITH
MEASURABLE EFFECTIVE AND
IMPACTFUL OUTCOMES.
SECOND IS REALLY TO YOU KNOW
THINK ABOUT HOW WE ARE TRULY
PRIORITIZING SMALL LANGUAGE
GROUPS AND NON FOR IN LANGUAGES
SO ONE OF THE COMMUNITY.
TIMES AND THE SOUTHEAST ASIAN
COMMUNITY IS THAT YOU ME AND
POPULATION.
AND SACRAMENTO -- WE HAD THE
HIGHEST UNION POPULATION --
OUTSIDE OF ASIA.
AND YOU KNOW I JUST HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM RECENTLY%
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES TO DO SENSES
OUT REACH AND THEY SAY NOW.
THEY CONTINUE TO JUST DO OUT
REACH ON A VOLUNTEER BASIS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM -- AND
THEN ALSO TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ME AND
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO BE
INVISIBLE RIGHT BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THE CENSUS DATA DOESN'T
REPORT.
ON THEIR ON THEIR DATA SO THAT
THEY REMAIN UNDER COUNTY.
AND THEN THEY DON'T RECEIVE THE
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES ON TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THEN LASTLY I ALSO WANNA
JUST REEMPHASIZE THE COMMENT
AROUND REALLY INCREASING
CAPACITY. FOR A CBO AND ALSO THE
SUMP SUBCONTRACTED CDOS TO CARRY
OUT THE NEW LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN
WHEN IT COMES OUT -- YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM -- OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND MAYBE
IT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT SENATOR PAN
HAS BEEN SAYING TO YOU.
IS THAT YOU KNOW THE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THERE BEING A
POTENTIALLY A NEW LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN THAT IT IT REALLY IS
SPLITTING THE CAPACITY AND FOLKS
ARE HAVING TO NOT THINK ABOUT.
HOW TO SPLIT THAT FUNDING?
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS LISA CHIU
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA.
A PARTNERSHIP OF ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS AND SAN FRANCISCO IN
ADVANCING JUSTICE LA ONE OF THE
STATE WIDE A C. B. S..
IT IS OUR PRIORITY THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS ACCURATELY
REPRESENTS ASIAN AMERICAN NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES.
WE CAN ONLY DO THIS BY ENSURING
LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR THE SMALLER
LANGUAGE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HISTORICALLY UNDERCOUNTED IN
LEFT OUT WHICH WILL NOT RECEIVE
ANY LANGUAGE SUPPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL.
CENSUS BUREAU.
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE STATE
PRIORITIZING LARGE LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT POPULATIONS
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALSO SEE MORE
CONCRETE MECHANISMS. FOR
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF SMALLER
ETHNIC GROUPS -- AS PRESENTED
TODAY.
WHICH HAVE DISPROPORTIONATELY I
ELLIE P. POPULATIONS WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT POPULATION SUCH AS
TONGANS SAMOAN AND MARSHALLESE.
NEED TO BE INCLUDED IN ALL OUR
REACH **** CONSIDERATIONS AS
THEY HAVE BEEN SYSTEMATICALLY
AND IGNORED AND THEIR NEEDS.
PERHAPS THEY WILL BE TRIGGERED
BUT PERHAPS NOT BECAUSE THE VERY
NATURE OF THE CENSUS IS TO DO
THINGS THAT WE'VE NEVER DONE
BEFORE.
THAT IS TO INSIST ON COUNTING
EVERY INDIVIDUAL ESPECIALLY
THOSE HARD TO COUNT AND THOSE
ONLY EXPOSED THROUGH THE WORK.
OF PEOPLE ON THE GROUND -- EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IN THE STATE THAT
FAILS TO BE COUNTED REPRESENTS
HUNDREDS OF NOT THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
OF LOST FUNDING AND EFFECTS
REDISTRICTING AND REPRESENTATION
ON A FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL AND WE
ALSO ADVOCATE FOR WORKING ITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS IN THE
REGION'S THE COUNTIES IN THE
CBO'S.
SO THAT OUTREACH AND LINGUISTICS
SERVICES BOTH ARE FULLY AND
FAIRLY FUNDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELCOME I ANGER AMONG THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA A LINE MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT SPOKE
pBEFORE ME IN CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
IS CRITICAL THAT THE SECOND
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN BE
OPERATIONAL HAVE FOR A BUS
DETAILS AND HAVE MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES IT NEEDS TO OUTLINED
HOW IT FILLS IN THE GAPS LEFT BY
THE FEDERAL PLAN.
AND IT REALLY NEEDS TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT SMALL LANGUAGE GROUPS
AND ON A NUMBER AND LANGUAGES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN
MEMBERS KNOW AT BOTTOM -- WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF WORKING ON THE
CENSUS.
OUR COLLEAGUES THAT CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE INC THE
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM -- WE ALL
WORK WITH FARMWORKERS AND
PARTICULARLY ONE THIRD OF OUR
FARMWORKERS INDIGENOUS THAT YOU
HEARD YOU SPEAK BEAST ACOSTA
POLITICAL INTRICATE SO THE
PRESENT CHALLENGES AND NON
WRITTEN LANGUAGES.
IN TERMS OF OF LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN YES WE NEED FUNDING WE NEED
THESE RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN HAS THE
FUNDING THAT'S OPERATIONAL
PARTICULARLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WERE
IT'S ISOLATED.
ITS VAST IT'S UNDERSERVED WE
HAVE OUR ISSUES WITH THE
INTERNET.
AND OTHER THE LANGUAGE AS WELL.
BOB SO IT'S GOT TO BE AT EACH
STEP OPERATIONAL AND COORDINATED
WITH WHAT THE CENSUS OPERATIONS
ARE DOING.
FILL IN THE GAPS THAT THIS THE
FEDS ARE DOING THAT'S CRITICAL
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
MEET OUR NEEDS.
YOU YOU SAID DR PAN TEXAS IS
LOOKING TO US FOR FUNDING HOW
COULD THEY GET THAT MONEY TO DO
THE WORK.
SO I AND THEN THE LAST PIECE IS
IS WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CULTURAL COMPETENCE IS IN PLACE
THAT WE DON'T ADD THESE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS BY.
PUTTING MEASURES OF SUCH AS
TARGETS THAT WOULD CREATE THESE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES WILL THEN SUFFER BY
NOT GETTING COUNTED SO WE GOT TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T DO THAT AND
JUST WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS ON
THE GROUND TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
A ROBUST.
COUNT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SCENES NOR CELLS AT THE
MICROPHONE -- WE HAVE COMPLETED
THE AGENDA FOR THIS JOINT
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEES ON THE
U. S. CENSUS SO I THANK ALL OF
OUR SPEAKERS ARE BEING HERE
THANK.
THE DRECTOR I COULD YOU FOR
BEING HERE AS WELL AND LISTENING
TO THE TESTIMONY AND I THINK ALL
THE MEMBERS. FOR FOR BEING HERE
MANY OF YOU ACTUALLY SPENT --
THE ENTIRE HEARING WITH US SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH THAT THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED